when you're out there you put your stuff
out like even in this podcast i learned
something so new about myself right yeah
i didn't realize that when i was
criticizing paying i was criticizing
myself because if i because i've been
through those situations and i started
getting heated because i started seeing
a younger version of myself as a kid and
i saw myself getting bullied and i saw
myself doing what he did and not getting
the result that i wanted and so it just
became something else it wasn't about me
looking at the situation and how he felt
and what he was doing i was i was
actually yelling at little in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast we have a very special
guest here we have an og comic in the
house been doing it for a very long time
one of the first comics that i actually
met when i came to los angeles we have
pk comedy here today thank you brother
hey nice house nice pad thank you for
having me man i've known or he's known
me for like what 10 years that's been a
long ass time a long time was the first
time we met respect for you so uh
first of all i'm so glad you brought me
here
did i not
i'm humbled when you're like do you
wanna i said hell yeah
i wasn't like let me check my skin i'm
like we'll figure that out later yes
first
dave is so man but i yes first and then
but then the second thing i want to say
just start this all out i'm like
i'm glad i could say it it's dumb but
after this i never want to talk about
ever again
because i have apologized to but there's
one time i wanted to apologize to you
for what
cause you came to collaboration and at
the after part i texted you like hey
i'll meet up with you i was just in
another world you know like ah all over
the place
and uh i didn't really like
go up to after and then until the very
end
of the whole party
i was like yeah yeah i'll meet you at
the party whatever but i was you know
saying like after the party i was like
in another bro i don't even know i don't
even remember any of this i do because i
remember on the way walking out and i
was like hey dfsar and then you're like
that's cool cool but i just felt so like
hollywood fake right at that moment you
know what i'm saying like i don't
remember anything
good good good because i don't want to
bring it up ever again i'm sorry i'm
like cool i actually brought here to
confront you about it you piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i was like that's why i invited you you
[ __ ] up it's like such a dumb moment
but i just remember feeling at that
moment like
it's so dumb like you know what's funny
he's just dumb and like hey i told i
said yeah i meet you and then i was
meeting like all these people after a
show
you know on a previous podcast with my
buddy ed i was i talked about that this
story about because danny cho hated me
so i didn't
i told the story where back in the day
where he dissed me super hard and i had
no idea why because i didn't know who he
was you know and i'm like why does this
guy [ __ ] hate me is it is it because
we look exactly alike like what the [ __ ]
is this about
and um it was a story where i told it
when we were in berkeley and we did a
show together and that's the first time
i ever heard of him
and i just thought he was like the
funniest guy ever i was like dude this
guy is so [ __ ] funny and then i went
up to like shake his hand he just like
kind of swatted my hand away and then
legit i almost beat his ass there
and then abe was the one that grabbed me
because i was like i'm gonna [ __ ] this
guy up and i was and i walked away i'm
like my feelings are hurt right now
because you know you kind of look at
this comic like this guy's so [ __ ]
good yeah but then i uh i was talking
about it with dumb and dumb was like ah
he's cool with you now i was like i hope
so i didn't do anything to him yeah yeah
but he's still so [ __ ] funny yeah i i
think i heard the story i don't know who
from uh and uh
you know i i love and respect you both
and uh you know danny and i we did the
kings of k-town i've loved him we've had
still like him we've had our hilarious
we've had our uh little tips too but man
mad respect for what he's doing in korea
yeah but i i can't help but so i put
myself in a situation like if i had uh
you know like a guy that looked like me
like some skinny fool that like had i
don't know like physically and he was
really funny you know and coming up and
and uh would i feel threatened yeah of
course
you know it's just something about it
like you feel a little you feel a little
threatened like because it's such a
small space especially in that one
along you know now there's freaking
there's hundreds of asian comedians but
even back then there were
like less than 50 i think you know you
know what was weird too is like i i've
never really felt that right so i always
felt that the table was big enough for
everybody to eat yeah so and if somebody
was better than me at something that
just means that they're dope at it and i
just got to work a little harder and
just do what i have to do so it never
felt competitive to me it was more like
oh this guy's dope i'm going to make
sure that everybody knows who he is
that's what i always felt like whether
it's whether it gave me light or not i
always wanted people that i [ __ ] with
to just always be successful yeah just
because in our space specifically as
asian comics i got tired of the dat fans
i got tired of a lot of these other comp
no like that fancy hey no lie when he
first came out thought he was hilarious
but his you know his set became very
repetitive yeah and it was just the
consistent which i like the asian accent
and stand-up comic says if it works it's
a part of your life it makes sense but
uh when i saw somebody like him it was
just very refreshing because he was just
funny just because he was funny right he
didn't have to cater to
all race jokes he didn't have to keep
doing the same jokes over and over it
was just about his life experiences and
what he observed so when i see other
comics i never thought hey this person
can take my spot it's oh this person is
dope i hope he's successful and i could
be there with them so
it's just it's like crabbing a bucket
thing right you don't want to keep
dragging other people because you feel
like they're going to take away your
success because if you do that you don't
really go anywhere you just start
becoming a very bitter human being yeah
you hate everybody that's doing well and
you spend most your time doing that
versus looking at yourself as saying i
need to get better like my standup needs
to be better and albeit it's hard right
especially when it comes to stand up too
like anybody who has a platform on
youtube instagram twitter whatever
suddenly they get a stand-up special but
cream always rises to the top because
you see those stand-up specials and they
are not funny
at all i've seen some of them yeah yeah
some are really good some are like i'm
not gonna lie i'm like damn man if i
hustle hard i should be up there man i
should i really feel that but then at
the same time i'm like i i have so much
further to go
but some of them are really good yeah
some yeah yeah some are
shout out which which uh twitter uh
comedian is hello funny to me well i'm
pretty sure they are but there's a
couple of i've seen it's just like oh i
can see people who have been on the road
and actually do stage work and crowd
work and they've been doing it for years
there's a difference yeah you know yeah
and there was a big period too where i
felt like a lot of older people were
looking at people like me who were on
youtube and other stuff they were
looking at us like i should have what
you have you haven't worked as hard as
me yeah you know and the hard thing and
what what did we find now all those
people what are they doing now they're
doing youtube they're doing instagram
they're doing twitter yeah so it wasn't
i deserve what they have is i wish i
would have done what they did yeah
totally and you could same here i could
have yeah it is a regret man it's a it's
a painful regret too but it's also it
keeps going generations like now with
tick-tock like you know what i'm saying
like with technology is you just got to
keep
staying on it like constantly it's like
just entertainment is fast now fast it's
almost amazing fast it's almost too fast
for me right so before we were able to
put up one video a week and you were
fine now it's like well for the
algorithm make sure you put up two or
three yeah make sure you're doing
instagram oh by the way there's tik tok
how many times are you tweeting a week
oh the videos are getting shorter yeah
it's like [ __ ] i can't i can't keep up
with this stuff right yeah but it's also
a matter of like how much do we care
about it for me i tried doing tick-tock
i got booted off the [ __ ] thing twice
i got my account canceled twice because
i curse yeah
you know oh you can't curse you cannot
curse so you say [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
titty whatever
you get a warning i got three warnings
got it canceled i did it again i got i
got my account deleted twice now so i'm
like ah [ __ ] it and then now instagram
is also like a weird space where if you
put a curse word into a comment they'll
give you a warning and say are you sure
you want to do this because it might
violate our guidelines and i'm like dude
there's no safe space for me
like this is hard you know cheers to you
though man just from the beginning i
think i mean we met i think before when
you did your the ucla girl right
you probably met me when i did that
right after that yeah right after it
literally immediately after yeah right
so you blew up and then from there and
then i just saw you do stand up yeah
um you know and i was thinking about on
the way here like i go we don't have a
friendship or like a close relationship
we have a
we cool ship you know we cool ship is
like people go you know david so i go oh
yeah i know him and then i like are you
guys friends like no we're not friends
but like we cool like because every
every time i see each other we're cool
you know you've always been cool so yeah
i love you man i love respect you and a
lot of times
like even even in uh social causes like
i i see what you do you encourage a lot
of people there's also a demographic and
and we were talking about this earlier
of people like me i work and have kids
and i'm in my corporate job
and uh
you say so many things that like you're
like
thank you
thank you thank you for saying this
thank you for saying it out loud and and
i guess we could say some people could
say it
but it definitely would make things a
lot harder for us to feed our kids
you know what i'm saying and then [ __ ]
your kids dude
but that's the hard part right like i
think
i think for me when i when i started you
know especially when i was in this space
i just i never did it because i wanted
to be
uh recognized exactly you know like i
wanted people to laugh and enjoy my
things but
i don't have that hindrance where it's
like will they like it if they don't
like it or will i take it down i've
always had do i like it if you like it
i'm really glad you enjoy it but i have
to like it first right so
people even ask too like i remember
years ago that what do you do if youtube
explodes i don't [ __ ] i don't care
like youtube can just explode tomorrow
i'll figure out another avenue then i
guess i'm back on the road doing
stand-up yeah like i'll figure it out i
just have to do what i enjoy and i think
it's always been hard for me to take
instructions to do stuff that other
people tell me to do that tell me that
it'll make me happy like i had that with
my dad my dad would always tell me that
this is the path in order for you to be
successful and happy and he never knew
what i wanted so i can't do that in a
career space either so i just have to
work that hard if i want to maintain the
lifestyle that i have and i just have to
find those avenues and it's happened
over multiple times yeah a lot of these
youtubers and um
entertainers that are on social media
that you don't see anymore the reason
why is because they didn't adapt they
just did everything based on what
everybody else told them to do they kept
doing the same thing over and over they
didn't think about their identity and
their reason why and because the reason
why was only to post for other people
after a while your clout disappears what
are you left with you're left with
[ __ ] nothing
very very true so it's hard right yeah
and i think like you got to adapt fast
to whatever whatever technology or yeah
yeah you don't you don't know what's
gonna happen next yeah you know nothing
nothing is permanent especially in
social media a lot of people come in
their their average career span three to
five years they make their money they
disappear and they're like still
searching for fame they're super sad
they're scratching for notoriety it's
like bro you made millions of dollars go
[ __ ] off and go do something else right
you know but they're still waiting for
people to look at them and it's like hey
i remember you from this video yeah i
remember who the [ __ ] cares dude just
[ __ ] be happy and do whatever the
[ __ ] you want yeah and i think like
being able to speak your mind it's
it's great and if people don't like it
they don't like it who the [ __ ] i don't
[ __ ] care yeah like i think stand-up
probably helped out a lot because when
you go up you do a set and it bombs and
it hurts why why did you stop i wanted
to do film oh okay yeah no because i
remember one day you put retired i'm
like oh wow i'm like okay yeah i just
didn't i i'm very like once it satisfies
a thing for me i move on to the next
thing yeah yeah it doesn't mean that
it's dead forever but i i think the i
remember when i put that there because
everybody kept on calling me a stand-up
comic and i felt like a fraud because i
didn't do it i stopped yeah i was like
don't call me a standard comic i'm not a
stand-up com not as an offensive thing i
just felt like it was i was being very
fraudulent
so that's why now i don't put stand-up
comic on my thing but have you have you
gone up or just to mess around a few
times if i want to do jokes here and
there yeah just to see if it works i
mean don't you miss it sometimes or no
as right now i don't oh wow so that's
the only reason why i'm not doing it
yeah so it's so you got to do our show
one time
i've been bothering you
one time no i'll do it you know thank
you it's on camera
don't cut that part out
i think the hard part is like uh
when you really like something like
stand up or you love it
all the bad stuff that comes with it
doesn't really bother you but because my
heart's not into it if i go up and i
bomb i think it's gonna hurt me more
because if i bomb before it's like hey
this is just a bad night you're gonna do
it six more nights this this week
anyways yeah who the [ __ ] cares yeah
yeah if i do one of them yeah and then
it stays on your mind for a while yeah
go in my car and cry
i'm gonna cry i've driven home in
complete silence many times no music
just driving thinking about what how did
i say it wrong like what i thought that
was funny
and just driving home in silence people
don't people don't know what that feels
like that [ __ ] wrecks you dude when you
have a bad [ __ ] set like
that that's why you gotta
go back to the next one because you
don't want that to linger you know what
i'm saying like you don't want your last
one to just linger it's a bad set that's
what i'm saying like before if i bomb i
just kind of
whatever move on now because i feel that
i don't really care for it as much
before plus you're you're so well known
there's like more pressure i don't even
think about that thank you so much you
know what i'm saying oh god i'm getting
[ __ ] nervous look because i've asked
ryan higa he was like alright i'll do it
once and then i was like come on
i kept asking and then he's like no no
no
a bunch of a bunch of youtube stars i've
been trying to get him to do it you know
and uh they're like
i could imagine there must be so much
pressure well you've done standup but
for them to be like no the first time
because they're already there's so much
pressure because they have to be funny
without editing with and they can't you
know you usually have to work up to like
a set but they have to be
you know
their fans don't know like yeah i mean
it's hard right because i think there's
such a big craft to it that a lot of
people don't know about exactly they
don't know about timing they didn't know
about pacing like even for me now like
by the time i stopped doing stand-up i
felt like when i was doing stand-up i
hated every single one of my sets even
if people were laughing and the reason
why is because whenever i got nervous i
got louder and louder and louder when i
should just be confident in the fact
that i'm [ __ ] funny you know and i
just never got to that point it was
getting there towards the end and then i
cut out when i now that i'm older i'm a
lot more confident now in terms of how i
present my material yeah so it feels
better now but i don't know sometimes
it's effective to get louder yeah for
sure if it's from your heart like i'm
all i'm always gonna remember i think
everyone is like when you're saying like
i mean this was like really fresh after
the atlanta shootings and you said uh
i'm just looking at it like right before
work and you're like man like we're so
asian americans we're expected to give a
[ __ ] about everyone but no
nobody gives a [ __ ] about us yeah in so
many ways i mean and he said exactly but
you said it like that like and at that
moment i'm like dude
yes
thank you
like thank you brother i was like
you're so invisible sometimes man or
we're just
like knocked to the side everyone's like
whatever
hello my lovely brain farts this podcast
is brought to you by four sigmatic
mushroom coffee my friends organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with lion's mane mushroom for
productivity and chaga mushroom for
immune support this just ain't your
morning coffee this right here is to
start your day for the rest of your life
it's super easy on my gut and i don't
get all jittery feeling or get that
midday crash which i do
not like remember my friends 100 money
back guarantee and best of all my
friends 20 000 5 star reviews so if
you're saying that a lot of people don't
know what's up with this oh i 20 000
people beg to differ in me included
because it's awesome i just do a cold
brew style i wrap it up in a cloth dip
it in that cold water let it steep for a
day or two and i have it in the morning
and it gets my day started so we've
worked out an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic on their best-selling mushroom
coffee but this is just for genius brain
listeners only baby get up to 40 percent
off plus free shipping on mushroom
coffee bundles to claim this deal you
must go to
com slash 4sigmatic.com genius this
offer is only for genius brain listeners
and is not available on their regular
website you'll save up to forty percent
and get free shipping so go right now to
four sigmatic dot com slash brain
genius and fuel your productivity and
creativity with some delicious mushroom
a coffee yeah it feels like sometimes
with like the whole asian american
experience
and i also think it's to our credit too
because a lot of just like culturally
speaking for like korean americans
japanese vietnamese whatever it's all
about doing work where people don't have
to praise you right that's why we have
trouble with a verbal affirmation hey
man you did a good job
we would say stuff like that yeah and
those verbal affirmations aren't really
needed even like look at japanese
schools right when you clean your
classroom your teacher doesn't go good
job you go no you did the task that
you're supposed to do yeah and i think
for for us too we just
our parents and this older generation
that's above us they just did
good deeds just to do good deeds because
you're supposed to do it and when bad
things would happen they're like ah
whatever and then move on because it's
i'm not sure if it's an ego thing but i
always looked it as this person if they
wronged me they're beneath me i don't
have to address it but now the
generation is different and it's shifted
right if we don't speak up about things
we get kind of pushed under the rug and
so a lot a lot with like racial issues
we're getting pulled to both sides it's
like if you're not saying anything they
go oh you're this asian person's trying
to connect themselves to whiteness oh if
you're if you're speaking for something
like blm it's like look at this guy he's
trying to be too black it's like then
when it comes to our issues it goes our
issues are bigger what are you
complaining about it's like okay so what
the [ __ ] do you want from me now yeah
exactly you know yeah so if i'm i'm
either too wide i'm either to this and
then when i have issues you say okay but
be quiet yeah you know it's like okay
then you know what [ __ ] all you guys
you know i'll support what i want to
support you know i'll support blm
because i feel like it's a big part of
my life i don't think you should always
[ __ ] on white people for everything but
when i have issues i'm gonna speak up
about it yeah yeah and you should be
able and i should be able to say [ __ ]
without you telling me that i'm [ __ ]
being a [ __ ] yeah you know yeah so
yeah man
that was the tough part
yeah you were speaking from your car
like to to the world man you know what
i'm saying was that that right out here
literally right out there in the car
yeah
i was like okay yeah i just you're just
speaking from your car like and
even that too i think that's it's cool
when you do that
because a lot of people we consume a lot
of media in the car and it's usually
alone yeah like to work and it's like
whatever you're whether you listen to
hip hop rock or for me sports radio or
talk radio
the car is something very real you know
because that's where you're i don't know
people turn into road rage in their car
too the nicest guy i had a friend like
super nice and then once he he just
started uh road raging in the middle of
the conversation and then went back to
talk to me normal and i was like [ __ ]
man
i was like thinking who are you bro and
so it's like a real place so when you're
speaking that from the video like there
were a lot of vlogs man that you
it was like game changing i mean it was
weird like i don't respect for that when
i did those videos
yeah i remember people saying from the
heart yeah you could feel it how long
did it take you to write that i was like
i gotta [ __ ] write that [ __ ] yeah
it's too fast for me to write you know
so i would just say what i wanted to say
i post it and i'm like whatever and i
would move on so i didn't really
go back and look at the videos because
looking at the videos made me mad you
know so i would just post it it's like
yo i wanted to say what i wanted to say
you take with it what you want and then
um yeah a couple friends were hitting me
up they're like yo you're [ __ ] video
circulating i'm like what [ __ ] video
are you talking about they're like the
video you did on instagram what the [ __ ]
and then you know million views x amount
of millions of views i'm like jesus like
i didn't know people
uh cared about content like that anymore
you know i thought they just wanted the
the [ __ ] pranks and the [ __ ] water
balloon in the face but i think during
that time because it was so yeah i mean
well of course the asian american
community what was encouraging were the
non-asian people that cared about it
yeah i mean of course and then there's
the drama and all this other stuff but
for the most part
that was the most encouraging because i
got dirty looks man during the pandemic
undeniable
and that's nothing compared to what so
many people went through but just
knowing that
clearly i got you know some just glares
and dirty looks in the grocery store and
the park with my kids
and just feeling this like like that
kind of you know and
one of my kids uh getting yelled at
corona you know just that
and then
like exponentially multiply that what so
many other people were going through is
just like man dude it's it was so
frustrating
it was frustrating and it was good to
hear people just talk about it we needed
it it was funny interesting it's like i
remember i told the story on the podcast
where somebody called me you people and
that [ __ ] made me feel so empowered
because i was like i have been waiting
my whole life to say the word you people
back at somebody with a question mark
like you people i was like you people
and i felt so good and then everybody's
like what do you mean you people and
they started jumping down this lady's
throat i'm like oh look at that dude
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] powerful like i
got to throw it right back in her
[ __ ] face but yeah i when you know
when you're walking around your typical
neighborhoods that you didn't have to
deal with this stuff before it was weird
i was thinking i i never had to deal
with somebody looking at me funny and
i've been walking around this neighbor
doing eight to four mile walks for the
past like six seven years yeah and it's
just a little too coincidental that
somebody calls me you people tells me
i'm the reason all of a sudden yeah it's
like what the [ __ ] like what what is
this [ __ ] um
i guess like for me too it doesn't
bother me as much because it's one out
of like 90 something yeah so out of 100
people one person says something i'm
just going to take that experience for
what it is and then understand that
there was like the other 99 that was
there being very supportive it's just
kind of emboldened a lot of people who
already had these feelings towards asian
people exactly it allowed them to say it
out loud because they don't feel like
they're going they're fearful anymore it
was this idea of oh now everybody knows
you're a piece of [ __ ] so if i say it
out loud i feel more emboldened that's
why people had issues with china virus
exactly a lot of people didn't
understand you know this is one time you
know first of all i i love the uh
how diverse your friends are and your
you know your love of culture but you
know my college roommates i went to
occidental college obama
uh
before he transferred out that's where
he smoked weed though
uh my roommate's white black latino i
was the asian guy we look like we always
called ourselves the college brochure
yeah we just needed a native american
dude you know middle eastern dude um
but you know i had a diverse group of
friends we're still close today during
the pandemic but uh
man the asian american community really
needed to support and continue to
support
the chinese community because they
just got the hate that the middle
easterners got after 911 you know what
i'm saying like just that
ah it's a different level and then a lot
of asians were like nah well we're not
chinese like we're you know it's just
like no man like they can't
funny story because you brought up
that fan who i love i opened for him in
hawaii a long time ago right and then we
had a show a little tokyo and it was
that fan and friends and uh
i was on it and then i sent my picture
to whoever the graphic person was
and uh you know paul kim but i put pk
but they just saw paul and on the fly
when it came out
it you know paul kim he was an american
idol
it was a picture of paul kim from
american idol even though i sent in mine
they got lazy and they just said oh just
paul kim and they're like oh we know
paul kim and i go i sent it to dad i go
dad i open for you bro and he goes oh
it's my graphic person but i'm like yeah
okay fi the fact that you know we all
look alike and just the same name it's
like even furthermore we should support
just like just like they should support
koreans you know i'm saying like in
terms of like
just being down for like
[ __ ] that they're calling it kung fu
they were spray painting kung flu
onto restaurants in texas
and people were like it's not a big deal
it's like yeah it is
it's hard right because and i know i
explained this before too and i'm pretty
sure you know if people think about it
they might agree is
the the idea the asian identity in this
country it's it's it's hard to compare
to black americans and mexican-americans
and the reason why is because
asians in general don't think of
themselves as a monolithic society right
korean japanese all this the languages
the cultures the behaviors the history
is all completely different when
somebody looks at somebody who's mexican
they think oh this person is from mexico
we can share these these certain you
know
cultural stuff that we're really proud
of yeah but you look at the history
between japan and korea it's very
different in fact we had our own issues
with japan and korea and the whole you
know the comfort women you know
so there's
it's it's not as easy for other asian
people because when they go oh you're
all asian it's not the same because when
we come to this country we actually come
to this country with our identity yeah
when it comes to black americans their
identity was stripped from them yeah
they were brought here as chattel so it
wasn't you know somebody from um
extra part of africa from this part of
africa and they still kept their culture
all that [ __ ] was stripped and taken
away from them for us when we came here
we came here with our culture our
language and our food and we created our
separate communities
so it's hard for us to for an older
generation too to say oh this chinese
person is also
uh asian like me they go oh these are my
korean brothers and sisters these are my
ch the language is different the culture
is different everything else so i think
for that generation it's difficult right
but i think one of the hard things for
that generation to understand is like
you might understand that but a person
who has uh who's racist who doesn't care
about what your language culture food
identity is yeah you're just a [ __ ] yeah
that's it yeah you know yeah it was a
hard thing for us so i had a friend who
who came on this podcast and was talking
about when she grew up her
she is an immigrant from um i believe
it's ghana i might be mistaken but it's
from africa right
her parents didn't like black americans
because they're considered immigrants he
goes we're immigrants we work hard i
don't understand why these black
americans they can't get their [ __ ]
together that's how they felt
um because in their eyes they're african
oh we're not black americans we're
african yeah but when they go out in the
outside world and somebody just looks at
them like they're black and they go oh
it doesn't matter what we think we are
to everybody else we're just another
black person and i think asian people
started to realize that now it's like oh
in this country though we do have our
own cultures our own language when it
comes to somebody who hates us we're
just the [ __ ] especially during the
pandemic that's what i'm saying like
this this should be the time where most
asians should understand like to come
together
but not really
i mean it's it's going to be
i don't know like i i always feel a
little weird about telling people how
they should
do their form of activism right yeah
because now when it comes to activism
there's social currency involved in it
yeah do we speak up because we believe
it or do we do it because of the optics
because of the way that it makes us look
true and so a lot of these conversations
that i have with the younger generation
they're just angry to be angry without a
purpose
that's the hardest thing about young
activism especially because it's like
comments you know anonymous
there needs to be an id like some
company that creates something where if
you comment it's connected to your face
like your driver's lice you know what
i'm saying he might have moved to china
bro
no but i'm just saying like it's this
anonymous troll it's just it's
it's ruining the country man ruining the
world man well this is what's happening
there was i mean there's like all these
like independent studies done um
especially with like a younger group of
kids on what apps like instagram and
social media does to their psyche in
terms of
how they thought about killing
themselves depression depression like
self-importance and self-esteem
um it's hard to escape yeah right i mean
you're a father like yeah you're gonna
have to my wife worries about it like
crazy and as she should be because it's
pretty scary how
somebody's value now is based on what
everybody else tells them and it was
always like that but before it was just
the village well now it's the whole
world yeah and if and it's like you
could see the numbers it's like a number
in your face your mistakes are amplified
yeah your victories are kind of brushed
off there's bullying cyber bullying
people love doing that [ __ ] right like
and i'm all for comedy and jokes or
whatever right but unless that idea or
mentality is given to the person like
like let's say your kids like hey this
is all for jokes just take it as jokes
and don't worry about what people say
just continue to do what you do this
podcast my friends is sponsored by
better help there is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
well guess what my friends i have been
there and i'm telling you right now use
better help if you haven't tried
non-traditional offline therapy see
traditional therapy can be really weird
for some people maybe some of you guys
have social anxiety maybe you feel weird
about meeting somebody in person
especially right now during covid so
guess what you can do it online you can
start communicating with a professional
therapist in under 48 hours and is done
securely on
line you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist which means it's super
accessible and better help is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches and my friends i've seen it
happen because a lot of you have been
dming me telling me that you started
better help and you started feeling
better which makes me feel great because
you guys are listening to what i'm
saying when it comes to focusing on your
mental
health so visit betterhelp.com genius
that's better h-e-l-p and join over the
2 million people who have taken charge
of their mental health special offer for
genius brain listeners get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
genius
and by the way no matter how many times
i say that i try to do that i'm not
gonna lie and things get under my
[ __ ] skin it's just i choose not to
let it last all day yeah gets under my
skin in that moment and then two minutes
later it's gone and then i move on from
it and then if you ask me about it in a
week from now do you remember that i'd
probably say no because not because it
didn't affect me then it's just it's not
a big deal yeah so everything's a big
deal now though like i said your kids
make a mistake
like an embarrassing mistake that [ __ ]
lives with them forever because the
internet yeah so how do you tell these
kids who are already impressionable who
already have like societal uh
expectations out of them in terms of
what it is to be cool and wanted that
hey when you [ __ ] up it's gonna stay on
the internet for the rest of your life
and you just have to learn how to get
over it it's hard well it also it
discourages them from trying
yeah like trying to make mistakes or
taking a risk because it's like you know
it could be like life ending you know
everybody's gonna hate me or
that's that's the thing too it's like i
wish i could
tell some of these kids what i do all
the time it's like you're gonna [ __ ] up
yeah exactly you're going to make
mistakes all the time i tell my kids to
make mistakes like it's learn now like
now's the time to make mistakes yeah
before you [ __ ] get a rap sheet that
lasts forever like just [ __ ] it make all
your mistakes now i say it too all the
time it's like the idea of being scared
is just an idea right once you get over
it it's it's in the past like you'll do
something right you're scared of it you
do it what happens next are you gonna
[ __ ] die absolutely not so take the
experience and then move on yeah it's
hard i get it it's [ __ ] hard and i
when people listen to this advice they
go oh it's easy for you to say
yeah but i follow through and it's
difficult yeah you think stand-up was
[ __ ] easy for somebody who has crazy
anxiety my anxiety is through the roof
like but i just tell myself to shut the
[ __ ] up and i go up on stage and then i
see what happens and like i say when i
go up and i bomb i go cry in my car
i scream i scream into my [ __ ] pillow
for an hour
and then i go up and i do it again it's
the idea that once again too people just
don't want to feel pain yeah that's how
everything is being built now yeah oh
you shouldn't say this because somebody
might get their feelings hurt yeah oh
you shouldn't do this because it makes
somebody else sad yeah guess what you
can't please everybody that's not
[ __ ] life yeah they're doing
everything they can now to make sure
nobody feels anything but happiness and
that is a complete farce it's not
possible yeah i hate that [ __ ] yeah
because now now when you when you say
something that people don't agree with
they go why are you being disrespectful
well my thing is why are you being such
a little [ __ ] like stop being a [ __ ]
if i have a point you disagree with
guess what you can do open that stupid
[ __ ] mouth of yours and tell me how
you feel disagree and then we just
disagree and then we have a drink and we
move [ __ ] on
it doesn't matter too it doesn't matter
if you want to disagree on something
like unless it's about ace like hey you
know what i can do i should probably
kidnap with children and i'm like hold
on a second you know
we can't agree to disagree on this but
it comes to ideologies like politics or
whatever if it doesn't affect you know
my life or the world in a negative way
and it's just a thought and opinion i'm
okay with you having it
yeah that's how definitely it should be
uh during the trump era though
uh i lost my my best friend during that
time he said we still haven't talked
and uh he's a troop
big time trump supporter which is fine
but uh it was just he he he changed man
and like it was just a constant uh
berating me and uh
i don't know we we couldn't talk like
like we used to be like
we like best friend he were each other's
best men each other's wedding
and uh
he just watched
certain media all day and read some
stuff and
but why was he coming at you so hard it
was just like we couldn't we we couldn't
avoid it it was like so intense during
that time and it just kept coming to
that and i'm a moderate liberal i'm not
a liberal liberal i'm like modern my
whole family is conservative yeah uh
you know so uh
it was just like this like calling me
libtard you you know and i'm like bro
and then we got on these group texts and
he would do it in the group text and
that's when i was like all right i'm
taking a break man why is he so pressed
though like i don't see that's what i'm
talking about too he's not trying to
have a conversation he's trying to
demean you for believing in the stuff
that you believe yeah and that's when i
felt like dude this ain't saying you
know just this isn't a discussion
anymore and there's more than that i'm
hurt like i thought we're home like
what's going on man like
so that's when i
took a break and then that break hasn't
stopped we just haven't um for me i've
always in our friendship you know for
it's been it was 20 years we
i've always been the one it's my
personality that's probably why i've
been married for 15 years is even when
i'm not right i say sorry for sure
just to keep peace you know are you so
nice dude but in this one on this one
i'm like no [ __ ] that i'm not i'm i
i'm not gonna say sorry first man like
if you want if you value our friendship
all you gotta do is just pick up the
phone and just say hey man sorry about
that and then we'll continue
he's so much pride
and i don't ever remember in our
friendship him ever seeing sarah buddy
he sounds korean to me yeah he's yeah
that's the most korean sounding man i've
ever heard in my life and i'm like all
right if you're getting it
my dad only said sorry to me once in my
life and he did it like slipped it out i
don't even think he knew he said it to
me
like we were he was looking for a phone
number and he messed up the number that
he was repeating back to me and he goes
oh sorry i was like excuse me
and that's the last time i heard it it
was when i was uh
that's funny i'm trying to think to my
dad ever say sorry my mom has literally
said to me i will never ever say sorry
if i'm quiet that means i'm sorry that's
hilarious yeah that's all those uh those
memes right all the asian parents they
say sorry about cutting up fruit yeah
she doesn't even do that she just stays
quiet and she stares at me and then she
just starts doing the dishes so there's
no sorry there's no sorry yeah there's
no sorry and i love you because my mom
was in korea and um like i always go um
i love you and she goes uh
she doesn't say it back
my mom started saying i love you in the
last like six or seven years yeah i
think more asian parents are like yeah
yeah my mom never said it before and
then out of nowhere she goes uh actually
i love you and i'm like whoa i was just
like
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah that's hilarious but now i say it
back if it feels pretty normal but it
took a lot of practice saying i love you
back to her my dad will never say i love
you we actually had a huge fight years
ago and that huge fight was the reason
why i got to understand who my father is
and i'm like oh you're just emotionally
stupid like you cannot it's not capable
because it wasn't taught to you and
you've gone 60 years of your life not
doing this i'm not going to try to
change you exactly you're going to have
an aneurysm that's just so true yeah
that's exactly why uh
guys dads husbands need to
continue to get together with other guys
and uh learn how to talk about real [ __ ]
like i have a mastermind group that i
form with a bunch of dads that live
around our area and every dad said dude
this has been a lifesaver we meet every
other month it's been like four years
and we go around first and you know we
have beer we go around and we just talk
about how we're doing and that's that
and then one each meeting someone
presents like a business thing or we
help each other out
that one thing has because you feel like
an island sometimes you know and like
korean men are taught not to express
their feelings and they're just
they're just you know
[ __ ] on all day at work and they come
home and they just like don't talk about
things so they just volcanoes man that's
why korean tempers like
well i think that's true too because i
feel like with my dad growing up he had
so much [ __ ] on his plate right so my
mom didn't really speak english he had
to do all the paperwork stuff he had to
do all the financial things had to take
care of the grandparents i was a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] we were broke as [ __ ] we
couldn't we couldn't really do much and
then he would be you know he's also a
pastor too so he's out here trying to
you know tend to his sheep in his flock
that's right and then after a while just
out of nowhere you know
yeah i just started snapping so yo where
the [ __ ] did this come from because he
has no outlet he's so busy helping
everybody else out he doesn't ever think
about himself no outlet and then he just
starts beating my ass
that i just gotta just over here duck
all these blows and [ __ ] you know what i
mean cause i yeah my dad was like that
too yeah a volcano man the the korean
yelling was so nuts man yeah one of my
mom's favorite phrases that she i mean
every korean parent i think said this or
maybe it's just my parents she goes
[Laughter]
you die i die we all died
just because i didn't eat my rice broth
like what the [ __ ] is that about are you
gonna [ __ ]
just [ __ ] take us all out yeah she
would always say that [ __ ] i'm like you
know this it's funny because as an adult
now i can just talk to my mom freely and
i remember the other day i was talking
to my mom i'm like hey why do you say
stuff like that like why did you why did
you threaten to kill me like so many
times
she sounds cute she's so crazy
she would she would just be so extreme
but i get it now though you know being
poor and trying to navigate this country
how hard was that for them too they are
first generation parents man heroes man
heroes yeah everything they went through
i can't even imagine you yelling at
somebody no no so i i i got my dad's
temper and it came on the worst times
i'll just tell you two short ones
embarrassing
one time's a house party like a dpd and
uh young so such everybody's over
uh my wife and then we're playing
cranium and we're
drinking like hard and then
drunk and my wife was on uh my boys team
and they were cheating and moving up the
piece without people looking and i saw
it because they did it multiple times
and i go i [ __ ] saw that and then
they're like what do i and i accuse and
i look at my eyes right and my wife and
my boy i go
did you move the p they both said no and
i go
i [ __ ] flipped my lid and gpd said
everybody at the house party looked at
their eyebrows went up because i [ __ ]
started yelling [ __ ] you i [ __ ] you know
i [ __ ] knowing what i saw and i was
about to flip the whole board
i went
over a board game right and everybody
was cracking up and i dude i i like
stopped the whole party for like 10
minutes i was going crazy and then later
about to go to sleep and then i was like
hey did you move she goes i did i go
i'm gonna kill you right now
do you know what a fool i made of myself
yeah i i was like pacing the house
i couldn't even and then another time
like at a collaboration meeting you know
what the funniest thing about that story
is is how you ratted out your own family
yeah
my wife no she's the on she's the most
honest person except at board games he
looked at your body like i'm gonna
snitch on you right now i'm like damn it
and then uh at a collaboration meeting
uh
danny chilling jason kim while
the other team was doing taboo they were
yelling donkey like like trying to
distract them donkey donkey donkey and i
was getting so mad because these were
like newcomers to
the staff and so when when it was their
turn to go and they're playing taboo
again i'm drunk
i started yelling donkey donkey dokie
[ __ ]
and everybody was like what the [ __ ] is
that with you know what you came for you
know what's scary about you is like you
don't get mad at things you should be
mad
you get mad at some of the
board games it's like something like it
came out man and that's why
yeah i probably didn't have an outlet
man like i'm like yelling at board games
that's the weird the funny thing is is
that people who do that they never get
taken seriously it's like because of
this yeah i know it's like i literally
stole a thousand dollars from you it's
like don't worry about that but the
board came why the [ __ ] would you do
that i know have you ever thought about
going to therapy and unpacking the [ __ ]
uh no but stand-up comedy has helped a
lot of companies not therapy it is no
it's not yes because sometimes you go to
you do a coffee shop like in thousand
oaks or whatever an hour away you don't
know a single person and nobody knows
you there and then there's times when
i'm not doing my set i just start
talking about my life and it and my wife
i we and i had gotten a fight and then i
come back and i'm totally a different
per at peace i let it out i think that's
the thing that's the difference
that's therapeutic it's not therapy it's
not yeah it's not therapy it's
therapeutic yes therapy is different
yeah because you have to unpack why you
do those things true and that's what a
therapist is for so all those things
that you feel that you might not feel
comfortable even talking to some of
these people who are your closest
friends yeah if you find the right
therapist they
it's weird it's like you have somebody
that you feel that you could tell all
this [ __ ] that you would never tell
anybody else yeah like i just remember i
went to my uh therapy session like a few
months back and i was like i feel pretty
good right and she's like talking to me
about my life and everything else that
she's not hot right huh no no no no
no she's she's cute did your fiance have
a say in this
let me tell you something my fiance is
never worried about me leaving her okay
i'm just saying but they just don't want
like a hot she's not very jealous at all
though okay because she's just there's
just so many movies and books about that
i'm saying that they're just well it was
a zoom therapy session so oh [ __ ] yeah
she just turned it on my legs were all
felt
[Laughter]
okay no i thought it was in person no no
no like uh we were doing it through zoom
and i just started talking and the next
thing you know i'm like
you know i'm like crying about [ __ ] and
i don't know why you know but there's
like things that they help you unpack
because they have all these like tools
and devices for you to use for you to
kind of reassess what's going on your
head and the why is the hardest thing to
find out before you do therapy yeah you
know that you are angry you understand
these emotions but do you ever say hey
the reason why i felt this way is
because i was embarrassed because you
made me feel like a fool because my
feelings were hurt you hurt my feelings
yeah one of the hardest things for ev
for me to ever say because i felt like a
little [ __ ] yeah so
i remember the other day mariel and i
got into a little argument it was very
small but she was doing something that
was irritating me and then i i drove out
and i was driving
and i was gonna drop it i was like no
i'm gonna tell her how i feel and i
called her up i was like hey
you hurt my feelings
she's like why why did i hurt your
feelings i tell well because you did
this and now my feelings are hurt and
she goes okay i'm sorry i won't do that
again but before i couldn't say that
ever i could never tell if my feelings
are hurt that's amazing yeah and even as
i say it right now i want to shoot
myself in the face
i love it
no i know but it's like it's like how
your mom can say i love you now you know
it's like growth but i have to
communicate these emotions in a way that
she understands i can't tell her it's
like hey you know what you're being
ridiculous
it's like it's not that what you said
hurt my feelings and i needed an apology
for me to feel better and because i
couldn't say that before she never
understood how i felt because if i told
a dude hey man you're being ridiculous
right now i feel like a dude be like i
i'm you know i'm kind of tripping
whatever i get it she doesn't
communicate that way she can only see in
her lens so if i could speak her
language then she could understand how
she makes me feel yeah so the you hurt
my feelings part was it i literally felt
like i had two [ __ ] pliers i was
pulling out my teeth
as i was saying it i'm like you hurt
my feelings
but the apology happened like that yeah
it's hard it's like well you're honest
and vulnerable it's like yeah because
imagine you know that vulnerability is
like super hard too yeah right because
especially if you can't off put it with
a joke
because that's what comedy is that's
well that's why a lot of guys can't say
i love you they go i love you man i love
you bro dude i remember that me and my
best friend i i'll always end the phone
call with like telling him i love him
and he always calls me a little [ __ ]
and then he'll do it to me and i just
like oh this [ __ ] makes me feel weird
but we've been doing it now for a few
years yeah yeah i mean but it's it's
always [ __ ] difficult but i've been
so open to saying i love you to people
now i say it to guys way easier than i
do to girls well like yeah i mean
because you're engaged now
it shrinks a pool of people you could
really say i love you to all these women
i really like i love you
i really love you yeah i know that's uh
the reason why i asked if like if your
therapist was hot is because we had uh
we used care.com to find like a
babysitter nanny yeah and uh you know i
lined them all up and then you know
obviously
uh you know tammy's not gonna choose
anyone that's remotely cute one of what
was cute and she's like she has no
experience and like it said she has like
it said like 15 years of experience like
she just completely looked over that she
goes she beats children
she beats them all the time she was like
it was at a church that's what she said
i'm like well what's wrong with kids
that are at church are they like not
kids or they're their kids and then
anyways yeah we uh yeah this didn't go
with the cute ones does your wife uh get
jealous sometimes no but it definitely
you know that's the thing about social
media too is like you have to be
conscious respectful i remember the
clipper girls all came
to laugh factory after they took a
picture they hooked my arms and i could
see her she's like oh okay so because i
pictured now picture time you got to
kind of be like okay like it's like you
like that you [ __ ] pun pass
[ __ ] no i'm saying like you
gotta you you gotta it's we it's bad
that if if the girl is not attractive
then when you take pictures it could be
like really friendly
you have to it's too obvious but if
they're hot then you're going to be all
like
no you got to start talking [ __ ] about
them it's like shut these bimbos right
all they do is talk about their [ __ ]
hair i'm so glad you're not like them
and then you sit there with your [ __ ]
dick all right it's like
yeah you guys sit like this well i think
the reason why she never feels any type
of jealousy she also knows i get annoyed
at people really fast and yeah the
people that i'm around whether they're
women men or not or doesn't really
matter who the [ __ ] they are their
status what they look like if you
[ __ ] annoy me i want you to [ __ ] away
from me yeah and i've always i've always
never
yeah i think when you're young and
you're a boy you're super horny you want
to be around hot chicks that period
ended for me really quick yeah and i
think it's because of my my temperament
as oh yeah definitely you definitely
have a fire temperament also as you get
older you're just less patient with that
kind of stuff yeah like usually you're
when you're young your patience with the
hot girl is longer
and then that just gets shorter and
shorter my my patience with people who
just are
really stupid and i'm not saying i'm a
really smart guy either but you are
it's like it's very very short like i
could literally care less every every
person that i ended up being with a long
relationship with is only because it's
always like i respected them first yeah
they were cute or whatever what not but
i feel like in los angeles everybody's
[ __ ] cute or attractive freaking
good-looking olympics in l.a can i try
this is yours that's uh tommy's drink i
mean you could open a drink
i thought this was like a like a soda or
something oh it's not it's a it's like a
for local energy vodka yeah it's a poor
local basically it's monday night right
hey man
it's
it's a saturday every day that's true
yeah
it's because you got so many kids man oh
yeah how many kids are you up three
damn 12 nine and six oh they're fine
then you know you don't have to take
care of them now they're good are you
guys thinking about it or no um maybe in
a couple of years just because i have
like so much going on right now yeah
yeah yeah i would definitely wait you
know when you have that kid it's a
different game-changer yeah i i still
have so much of my own personal wants
and things that i want to do and i feel
like i don't want to have a kid to the
point where i feel like i can't make
moves because of them because if i'm a
dad i'm a dad like i'm going to want to
be around for this kid it wasn't like
that for my parents they had to work all
the time yeah so you know had money on
how would you raise me so
i don't want that i want to be able to
like
have a conversation with my kid i want
to be able to chastise him without
socking him in the face you know
i think he'll be a great dad man
i see bart too man i'm like wow that's
really cool man bart's bart i think i
just remember when they first started
their channel dude i remember i'd give
them all the pros because i remember
they said like
mom or what is it barter joe like can we
just can you just support us just these
few months till we get it going i don't
know how long it was
and i just remember looking at that mic
dude those guys are going to make it man
those guys are just they're putting
everything in just all in
did you always do a stand-up and then
another job
yeah
how do you do that that's just so
[ __ ] hard that's why i'm just moving
so slow i mean no excuse too i should be
more disciplined but it's also three
kids and i have a full-time job and i
emcee weddings and i'm always involved
with a community but uh
just like i'm just thankful for like one
spot a week that's it but for me it's
like like not therapy it's therapeutic
yeah it's amazing like for me it's
feeling like i just
i'm always gonna try to make it of
course but i also know like a lot of
people have just completely stopped and
they're like giving up on everything and
i'm like
no for me it's like i'm gonna just keep
doing it and see where it goes because
even if
i don't ever make it like i've opened
for joe coyne and wrote on his tour bus
and i'm like that never would have
happened
if i wasn't just continually just doing
stand-up
but i always had to have a i always have
to live yeah
so for you do you ever feel and i always
wonder this too it's like
do you feel that if you gave up on your
other stuff just to work on it for like
a couple years
do you feel that that would be your big
step up yes and i i know a number in my
mind i need to have for me to take a
year or two off
and with three kids it's a lot man it's
a lot especially in la and uh yeah we
live in a small house and we're still
but you know i'm just thankful i'm very
grateful and i do
cherish this time because
our family since we live in a small home
we're always around each other
and
it's made me love my kids in a way where
i don't know if i would i'm not
i don't know i can't i just don't like
god or anything but if we had a bigger
house would i be as close to them i have
to be close to them we're always in the
living room together in my face yeah
like i get uh no i go to the backyard
just to just to go to the backyard
sometimes just to get out and then but i
am so close with them and i work from
home i i'm a recruiter from home but i'm
just i'm doing the drop-off pickups
i i i it's amazing at the same time i'm
like damn man they watch what i do like
i have a bit about masturbation and now
my oldest is like
he you know he's like hey me my friends
have seen it i'm like oh man it's like
now i gotta kind of like
okay like now all his friends are
watching all his parents are watching it
i'm like okay dude can i tell you the
most uncomfortable thing that happened
to me today when you talk about being
online and all your shit's out there
yeah so as i was walking i was telling
the story to my buddy khalif about
a buddy of mine who's gonna stop uh
being a pastor at his church because of
all the korean drama that happens in
korean churches yeah and we were talking
about it and lo and behold the person in
front of us is a bishop and he turns
around and he's like oh hello brother
how you doing it's like oh so what
church do you think he starts opening
and talking to me about christ or
whatever and then he says the one thing
where's your instagram i'm like
ah
you know like what's yours oh you're
talking about god church and christ and
the things that i've done i was a youth
minister for a little bit were you
really yeah i was a youth minister for
like two or three years so in sacramento
yeah damn
so
this is why people think i i speak very
prophetically and it's because of
training so yeah wow yeah it's like
junior high or high school or so i was i
was doing like online uh seminary school
during this time when i was trying to be
a pastor
because i thought it was my calling and
i thought i [ __ ] hate people so i was
like whether you go to hell is your
choice or not and if you're there and
i'm there well you better watch out i'ma
beat your ass there too i thought it was
my calling and i realized i [ __ ] hate
that's really what happened these kids
dude there's a few kids at the church if
you guys are watching i really liked you
but the ones i didn't like i i really
hope you died now that's one of the most
real things i've heard in a while man i
i i thought it was my calling but i
realized i [ __ ] hate people oh
that's that's real church [ __ ] dude i
had to deal with so much [ __ ] oh
yeah i know of course my dad's church
still is like that drama
the elder spot underneath you know they
said it in creed in english the little
with the black brush like yeah yeah yeah
they were fighting underneath love is
patient love is kind i'm never gonna
forget that and i was i was started
getting tired i was like what are you
guys doing the police came in the
champions were doing the you know the
front kicks
i [ __ ] love
dude they were doing that in suits and i
was like why is it that that happens at
every korean church that i've been legal
pride politics i went to a korean church
and this was during the the adult sermon
they were like they were basically
assigning new people to be deacons and
they're looking for a new head pastor
and the head pastor was going to leave
he wanted to address all the drama and
he starts talking up there he starts
preaching goes does it if anybody has a
problem say it now one of this guy's his
name was sean his father stood up he's
like you started [ __ ] cursing him out
in the middle of church in the middle
series goes up they start fighting the
the guy sean this dude was on like on
roids so he was super short-tempered
goes up and knocks out the head pastor
in the middle of the service in the
middle of the [ __ ] service
you want to talk about somebody who has
the fastest ticket to hell that it's
going to be that guy oh [ __ ] wait was it
a clean it was a clean wax
and the crazy thing is like we knew
about this guy's short temper because we
would have turkey bowl we would have the
church football flag football thing this
dude was so shroided out i remember i'm
a big guy how old is he he was like
eight years older than me and i'm like
uh maybe like a junior in high school
and we're playing turkey ball he knocked
out the head pastor yeah he was like 20
something years old he knocked out the
head bastard i will forever remember
that [ __ ]
because i i didn't like him because he
would always take turkey ball too
seriously like all korean people with
volleyball and football and flag
football and i remember just because i
was a big guy i got the ball i received
it and this full hit me so [ __ ] hard
i flew in the air i was parallel to the
floor and i had time to think about my
life
but i was just sitting there just like
why am i doing this what is the purpose
of this and then i hit the floor the
wind came out of me
i'm like bro you're like 28 years old
why would you do this to me i'm still a
kid yeah but he didn't give a [ __ ] and
those are the [ __ ] that we always had to
deal with at churches these [ __ ]
crazy people yeah i have so many weird
church stories i got one almost i think
this is just this goodbye that that one
is crazy bro i've never heard of the
head fast get knocked out this is my boy
dave he was one of my groomsmen too he
went to uh a church in k-town uh is a
really uh popular one fgla a lot of like
uh you know gangster guys used to go
there too but it was like a
high school group where you know they're
trying to get him involved give give uh
give him a guitar to leave praise and i
guess like the uh lead singer said like
okay like you're gonna get to um
close like the songs you know that's
like a shine right like the final songs
and then they're praying and i guess
right before
yeah i don't know this guy did uh this
guy did a whack move too like the lead
the lead praise guy's like no actually
i'm gonna close even though he like you
know made the offer or whatever
goes up
and uh
he went up to uh you know lead the
finals two songs or whatever and he goes
let's pray and when he went to let's
pray he just hear my point everybody
just was praying and everybody would
open their eyes
they heard the guy go
this guy straight up was choking him
dude what choking him because he was
like you like you know you said i was
gonna you know close this and get the
[ __ ] out of here
the holy spirit has taken over him he's
like no he's being choked to death dude
how [ __ ] funny that people are crazy
hypocrisy it's like all the praise is
supposed to be for god but clearly it
was for his ego yeah and they just
that's how they're funny and then i
think that same leap praise leader they
formed a praise man i'm butchering the
story sorry dave but they had a
they called the praise down for fun
double dragon right he had like two or
whatever
and then like there was another a dude
that was weird and i guess they were
like praise band b or whatever and they
felt inferior and they all went out you
know friday night bible so you go out to
either like ihop or denny's whatever and
they were just messing around going yeah
we're double dragon you know
and then all of a sudden the guy goes in
front of everybody you pass everybody he
goes man [ __ ] double dragon
oh my god because you guys [ __ ] like
he was just so bad and everybody was
like
dude we just had bible study
okay
i think i throw this on the podcast too
and if you guys heard the story i'll
tell it again
so when i went to uh church in college
right there was a small korean church
that i attended and i joined the praise
team well when you join a praise team
you have fellowship you get to know
everybody i'm kind of the misfit right
because i was trying to get closer to
christ but really i just didn't [ __ ]
like anybody but i went there and i
wanted to join praise i wanted to play
music and i remember there was a guy
that i knew that went to college
that went to uh the college that i was
attending to in riverside and then he
also went to um
he also was from my hometown and he
transferred over here to this to this
school he said oh let's attend this
church together so why we decided to
join praise together well we had to do a
fellowship thing where we kind of tell
our testimony right and everybody's
telling the story this is one of the
things i hated about church i hated
doing the testimony [ __ ] because
everybody would always over exaggerate
their [ __ ] you would hear a violin
playing as [ __ ] pedals falling on
their phone exaggerate i got i always
got emotional yeah everybody kept crying
and i'm like you little [ __ ]
you would have thought it was such a
[ __ ] i always
especially had the retreat oh my god
dude last night
the last night i couldn't help it man
i never cried oh man i always cried
everybody would just tell their story
and i'm like they said not bad
it's okay it's like regular stuff like
once again this is me being a very toxic
young man
but he started telling his testimony
right and i know this guy i know his
whole history has passed we've been
friends for a very long time and he
starts telling about this time that uh
he tried to kill himself so he sits
there and he goes
so the funny thing about this dude is
that he grew up
in the states but went to korea and
states back and forth multiple times so
he has a thick korean accent can't can't
speak korean at all one of the worst
things that could ever happen to you so
he and i found this out when we went to
go eat at a korean restaurant and i was
like hey bro can you just order the food
for us he's like i can't do it i'm like
bro just order the food he goes
i can speak a korean and i'm like bro
you speak korean like i can't speak it
well can you just order the food for us
because i can't communicate with this he
goes
i can't do it and i started pressing him
and everybody's like yo dude he can't
speak korean i'm like he can [ __ ]
speak korean look at his thick ass
accent
and then he's getting super embarrassed
and like bro like he kind of he doesn't
speak korean he's been i was i felt so
bad yeah how does he not speak korean i
don't know and he can't speak english
either that's such a funny character dog
it's the funniest thing ever this guy is
hilarious can't speak english well can't
we just do a youtube thing
that's a funniest character though you
just wait for this story like i
literally wrote a whole thing about this
guy oh because i want to do a whole
series just about korean culture she's
so funny yeah so there's this moment
so we're we're having this pray this
this part where we basically do our
testimonials and he starts telling the
story about how he tried to kill himself
and he goes yeah you know i tried to
cure myself after i graduated from high
school i'm sitting here like
okay i know this story right
so he starts telling the story and he
goes
so i
felt like he was the pastor asked why
did you try to kill yourself right
because he wants you know this open
heartwarming feeling in this meeting he
goes why did you try to kill yourself he
goes
so i just felt like i couldn't do
anything right and i jumped out of a
second story house and i couldn't kill
myself
and i went
and then everybody's looking at me and
they go why are you laughing i was like
because it's ironic that the reason why
you try to kill you is because you
couldn't do anything right and you
couldn't even [ __ ] kill yourself
and then the pastor looks at me
and starts
crying laughing he starts oh really
busting up laughing
and so
let everybody laugh everybody starts
laughing
has not talked to me since oh shut up it
has been 12 years oh come on he didn't
know that it was i mean i was laughing
because it was like
it was only the second story
come on bro exactly the second people
just break their legs all the time
he tried to kill himself by jumping out
of the second story of his house which
is not tall enough that's not tall
enough and he just broke his leg or his
arm and then
the funny thing is so he didn't he he
still he took it personally so he took
it personally because he i got the
pastor to laugh at him so he was so
embarrassed but it's just it was so
funny that this full tried to kill
himself because he couldn't do anything
right but he couldn't even kill himself
how [ __ ] funny is that how can i not
laugh
and so it's just the whole character of
his fob accent but then he does this big
correct
this gets [ __ ] worse this story gets
worse
so
he also wasn't completely truthful in
why he was trying to kill himself too
because he got his heart broken by this
girl you know there's like always that
one church girl that everybody is in
love with that they want to marry and
this was his best friend so when they
graduated high school together he
thought it was his chance to go ahead
and woo her before he leaves to say what
he finally wants to say so on graduation
day he gets two hamsters
one he names after himself and one he
names after her a little creepy comes up
and he goes hey like i've liked you my
whole life i want to get together with
you and i got you this parting hamsters
two hamsters right gets rejected he's
devastated
takes those two hamsters goes into his
room doesn't leave his room for a whole
week shut up right well in that whole
week he forgot to feed his hamsters it
died so check it out funniest thing ever
god is the funniest teacher on earth
literally what happened the hamster that
he named after her ate his hamster the
one that he named after himself
yes
they're cannibals they're cannibalistic
the best symbolism ever oh my god the
hamster he named after the girl [ __ ]
ate him and he said the only thing that
was left was one rib
and i laughed in his face super [ __ ]
hard he keeps telling these stories as
if it's this testimonial that we're all
supposed to feel sad about and i can't
stop laughing
this dude is the saddest person i've
ever met he still hasn't talked to me
since he's mad i'm pretty sure he's
still mad and now that i'm telling you
on the podcast i'm pretty sure he's not
going to be happy make it out into a
netflix show give him royalties
that's hilarious honestly dude that's
crazy the worst thing his luck is
terrible well it's also well it's not
more than just luck and like there's no
ninji like dude you just say the way you
presented two is like cave of two
hamsters like what girls could be like
oh my god
thank you for naming this hamster after
me you [ __ ] psychopath
dude church people were always a little
uh well it's because also you you're you
should out of god's love except everyone
but you do you accept
everyone all the [ __ ] gangpets that
were there were always the funniest to
me because they were just there for
[ __ ] yeah so they just wanted to hunt
all the cute girls yeah and that's why i
like some of them are cool but some of
them that were just not nice but then
just were like taking the girls away and
i was the praiser i'm like
those [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i've been
working on her for a whole year oh my
gosh she was the transparency girl but
now she sits in the back
now she sits in the back we she used to
nod at me
next song you guys don't know [ __ ] about
those transparency papers man the girls
used to write the praise songs and these
to do the translations and then they
would write the chords on top chords on
top yeah
were you a praise team yeah of course as
the you know it's just your son you
always have to be involved so that's
hella funny yeah but i i remember i'm
such a hypocrite because now we go to
church just once in a while and you know
you see those families just come once in
a while and i'll and praise i'd always
just see those families come once in
online all right yeah i know they're
just gonna come once in a while but i'm
like that's us
we go when we can you stop going every
week
yeah well after the whole the church the
you know fight uh i was like okay i'm
gonna take a break that's the first time
i used to go every friday saturday
sunday my whole life and then uh
went
started going raving with my friends
that left church like grew up in church
but they were raving
and then i you know normal progression
people go into kate they start smoking
drinking
shooting pool right that's the no
i went straight from like so like
nothing goody goody virgin
to ecstasy like every week and i was
like this is what people do
i was crazy dude imagine that and then i
was wearing big baggy jeans that was
visor my the first rave my friends lost
me and when i was walking back to the
car they were on the ground because
they're like what the [ __ ] happened to
you i had
like bracelets and candy all over i'm
like i just told everybody it was my
first time and they're like everybody's
your first time that's like a whistle
funny did you have the pacifier too dude
and then uh i was a hardcore raver for
years and then i
stopped going to church because i was
just all about that for a while
and then and then i went backwards then
k-town clubbing and then drinking
backwards do you [ __ ] still go to
blue and [ __ ] uh
ever since inner crew opened i i stopped
but i miss blue that's like my
my favorite place that's santa cruz is a
little too like
big i love inner crew but blue is always
one of those spots it's like either it's
gonna be a really chill night with a
bunch of people there or some shit's
gonna happen sometimes there's some
drama sometimes one time so i was going
to go to blue because a couple of my
friends were a couple of homies were
there i'm like i just like i don't want
to go because i know something might
happen it's like it looks like there's a
lot of people there and usually some
[ __ ] will happen but blue's super duper
spot
and then i go in and then literally this
young person comes up to me and he puts
his hand on my chest he goes hey dave is
so right i'm like yo i'm a big fan he
goes hey hey hung don't go in there
right now i'm like
why here he goes just don't go in there
and as i'm walking away they start
jumping somebody right in front of a
bluetooth and i'm like
i'm not coming here anymore
i'm gonna go this way i've never seen
that there's always some [ __ ] happening
i've definitely seen some gangster guys
there yeah gangsters make my ass wet bro
[Laughter]
but the reason i love blue though is
more like it's such a there's like
business people and then the usuals and
then there's you know we know all the
bartenders and then i feel like if you
guys go to k-town
blue is like a staple blue is like one
of my favorite places in the world i
there's so many times i emcee weddings
and i don't want to go straight home
because straight to blue because i'm in
a suit and i know if i go home my wife
and kids are sleeping on saturday night
i know exactly what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna get in and out burger we live next
in and out and then i'm gonna eat i'm
gonna jerk off and go to sleep it's like
it's like and it's kind of lonely you
know and then i know i'm like
i need to go to church tomorrow
so i'd rather go to blue at least i'm
gonna have like you know human
interaction
the funniest thing was like i remember
when i started getting into like serious
relationships and
jackoff time was and when you're single
and you're alone is any time anywhere
the [ __ ] i want right and then you start
sleeping in bed with somebody that's
next to you yeah and then all of a
sudden they have dreams about an ocean
they know why
it's because you were too tired last
night so i had to release some stress
and they're like what the [ __ ] was there
an earthquake in last night i'm like
yeah it was a 4.7
it was crazy last night it was it was it
was crazy i swear to god
yeah now i'm at a point where now
especially during the pandemic
uh where you know my wife just she don't
know she knows what's going on she
understands she's just like just turn
off the light before you come to the
room she knows when i'm doing my little
man cave just don't sometimes you leave
the light on
why is all the switches so sticky in the
house
at least clean it up i can lotion on the
mouse
but uh it's because also too she's tired
man she's just kind of like just you
know it's a mature way of like i know
do your thing you know when did that
change for you guys because how long
have you guys been because when we had
our third kid it was like
she's exhausted man like it's so
exhausting just like from one one to
three it's like so hard four and up is
amazing one two three especially the
first just watching them all just like
in the middle of the night you have a
road to you you take turns but if when
it's your night you're just on it like
okay
two two a.m you gotta feed you gotta go
down and you gotta like you know rock
them back to sleep and sometimes it's 30
minutes to an hour it's 3am you're like
and it's like it goes on for a year dude
you're just exhausted and you got to
wake up and go to work and so you're
like
and then you don't as a man you can't
breastfeed that you got to have the
right not to speak for yourself bro
for many years
these kids are going to be confused
they're just latching nothing's going to
come out
uh yeah so that's what all my friends
say like when when they start having
kids
having sex is hard oh yeah like it has
to be planned and scheduled just to find
these pockets and it's not the uh
passionate i have a new bit where i talk
about like donald duck sex and you know
it's such [ __ ] sex because
like you know the kids just sleep in the
other room whatever or let's say
sometimes you even you know you try it
like let's say we had a vegas thing we
had a sweet and she's like are you crazy
i'm like come on
like but there's no physical intimacy
you both have your shirts on just in
case but then just because you want more
physical see you both lift your shirts
up just to press your chest but then
it's still it's still
it's still around your neck just in case
suck
just in case
cause you know you want that you know
[ __ ] it's been a long time he's like i
just want to touch him
all right let's go
that's [ __ ] funny real yeah tammy
will kill me if she ever knows if i ever
talked about this on a podcast but it's
real man i bet you so many married
couples like he was like on a pocket and
it's still rolling and still recording
babe yeah hey this that's you know
that's the thing too it's like when i
was talking to mario she goes you keep
telling these personal stories it's like
that's my living yeah this is all i have
yeah our funny life experiences or other
people relate to as long as it's real
they're going through the same thing
yeah it's just comics talk about it
openly yeah like like marital sex issues
when you have three kids in the house
people know about this stuff they just
don't feel comfortable talking about it
physical intimacy is so important in
marriage and it's like you know it's not
the most important thing but definitely
when you are
physically intimate regularly
there's a peace in the house
because
things are going all right know if
they're not going to write then usually
it's not going to there's not going to
be can you just send the kids with like
harmony and haraji or somebody somewhere
no because you know uh my mom's in korea
my dad passed and then her
dad bounced and she was young and then
her mom's
super tired and uh and still working
which we all feel bad about so we're
trying to
have the options so
there's no there's no options man and
it's like yeah we just it's hard you
know that's why people started putting
their kids in summer camp
like probably i didn't know that until
uh like all my all the white homies told
me that like my parents put us in summer
camp because they wanted to get rid of
us
so they could just be alone for like
just like three weeks party yeah just
three weeks they were paid just so we
could have fun and teachers there's all
this other [ __ ] all that stuff was
[ __ ] they just wanted to [ __ ]
they wanted us out the house and they
wanted to [ __ ] just have some like adult
time alone time see you see if you were
still going to church regularly [ __ ]
retreats they would all be gone yeah
that's you gotta send them off to
retreats that's what you have to do they
gotta send them the retreats so you
could [ __ ] reconnect and just stop
doing donald duck [ __ ] and [ __ ] dude
is the worst that's hella fun it's just
functional
because you know she's already she's
thinking too like you know what if and
it's not this it's not it's like when
chris shaw talks about
the jerk when someone else is in the
room it's not it's not a safe jerk
you're like who's there
you don't say
it's different when nobody's in the
house it's so funny when i was younger
too like i talked about some podcasts
too where when i was young i don't think
i would ever just openly admit this
stuff but after a while your shame just
starts to go away you don't [ __ ] care
when i was a kid
i used to get so horny and i would i
would work in my parents store right
every now and then
a customer will come in and she'd be
fine as [ __ ] it's like the worst thing
that could ever happen because i'm at
the store working the register with my
parents i just wait for them to look
away i gotta use the bathroom i had to
go in and jack off just so i could do my
job because i couldn't focus so i would
just try to do it as fast as possible
come outside and i would just go back to
the register just all sweaty as [ __ ] and
it clears your brain and it clears my
brain now now i can like start
calculating [ __ ] super fast i know the
price of all the products but like i had
to do it
i was like
it's crazy it's i've had times when i've
had you know like my friends and they're
like hey man my wife's taking the kids
to her moms let's go party this weekend
and i can't because i we had family i
just have to like jerk off really quick
and i'm like hey man you go have fun bro
like you gotta have fun with the guys
you know i'm tired like because it just
clears your brain that's the best thing
to do when i would do when i would do uh
shows right and i was traveling and i'm
like listen i'm not trying to to [ __ ] or
hook up with anybody before i would go
out to the after party i would jack off
in the hotel first so my mind is clear
and then i would go and i would just
have regular conversations with people
how's your day
what are your what are your life plans
oh i'm glad that my mind is all clear
i'm not horny and i'm just having great
conversation i would go back and be
perfectly fine it works but if i didn't
do that it was a disaster yeah
especially when you're younger hell yeah
dude when you're like all you're
thinking about especially i i lost my
virginity late like at 20 and a lot of
my friends are all last 16. so i but
once i did i was just constantly
thinking about
oh damn like yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] some
girl like i was just like i
i remember it literally switched me
because i i didn't like this is what
this feels like yeah because even my
first girlfriend we didn't have sex like
my oh
my i don't know can i say what city
living you don't want me to say because
i'm sure okay
uh
arcadia you know is uh
first girlfriend our kitty i had my my
first car was a 900 volkswagen golf
stick shift the front bumper used to
fall off and one of our first dates i
picked up
picked her up from arcadia high school
uh the front bumper fell off it was one
of the most embarrassing moments about
and she helped me put it back on and it
started to rain and i was like just get
back in the car i got it the korean
range started coming out again
just get back here you stupid [ __ ] i
[ __ ] love you let's [ __ ] later [ __ ]
you like what's going on bro it's about
this guy's rage it just comes out the
wrong time
we're gonna go play more games later you
[ __ ] cut
[Laughter]
down people's hell abusive [ __ ] oh no
yeah
so are you gonna suck my dick
oh
yeah so that's uh that was uh my arcadia
story i wanted to tell you before i
forget for my first girlfriend but we
never because i was at church crazy i
felt really good i felt guilty so we
didn't we didn't have sex so
eventually you know once i did i was
like damn dude like a guy likes his
whole brain switches i wish one of the
things i don't have a lot of regrets in
my life and in fact i would damn near
say i don't have zero regrets but one
maybe one thing i regret or i want to do
if i could go back in time and change is
i want to go back and then refuck all
the girls that i had sex with in the
beginning
because it was such trash penis
i gave them the worst time of their life
i feel like i need to redo it i agree
because i didn't know what i was doing i
totally agree i had no i was just i was
just so grateful that they would allow
me to touch them
you know so i just
in my mind i was thinking oh you're you
i can see you naked you know i was so
just
amazed by it and then i didn't know what
i was doing and i didn't realize like if
once it was in it just felt great for me
i didn't know what it felt like for them
you know nor did i care at the time
because i was super young yeah and then
i remember
i think it was probably the third person
i ever hooked up with
and she gave me the worst hand job i've
ever had in my life and in my mind i
thought there's no such thing as a bad
[ __ ] or hand job because i just want
anybody to touch it and you know if they
touch it you know
they're doing god's work so that's
charity so i remember when she gave me a
hand job and it hurt so bad i was
thinking oh my god is this what those
girls felt when i gave them terrible sex
in the beating because i had no idea
what i was doing because this girl
talked up a big game as if she could
give the best hand jobs ever and then
she was trying to rip the foreskin off
my penis i will i forever remember it my
if my dick was hard to be getting soft
right now
it was the worst experience ever i think
every guy uh yeah it remembers their uh
their best and their worst yeah they
want yeah you know what i'm saying like
we all have that experience
yeah i gave a lot of bad penis and i'm
so sorry
and don't go around telling people about
that i was really young i didn't know
what the [ __ ] i was doing trash penis i
remember one of my uh friends he's a
young older
uh
she got so many girls we like don't ever
do this game we say let's say at the
same time like how many girls you've
been with in your life
his his was in the um triple digits and
mine was so far below that i fell to the
ground laughing because i was like yo
did did he die from aids like what the
[ __ ] no but i believe him yeah i was
like damn man yeah it was in the
hundreds and i was in there that's he's
a sex addict though that's a lot
that is a lot i mean yeah well yeah
that's a lot dude yeah that's also a lot
of work to hook up with that many people
you have to work hard for that [ __ ]
unless he was really good looking yeah
he is see i hate that [ __ ]
i hate those people so much
because you know like you would have
really good looking friends and then you
would go to a bar and
it's time to do work
and they just walk in and then it's
there or they they they're the
mysterious guy the guy that doesn't talk
yeah and then we're like trying to make
people laugh the whole time the whole
time
i always say this you have no idea how
hard it is to giggle your way into a
[ __ ]
and guys use whatever they can because i
remember one time i went clubbing with
uh korean effects you know people yeah
and i swear to we're all hanging out and
i thought he was whispering to a girl
but i straight i put my ear closed and
he was
like and i'm like yo bro but he took her
home
terry you are such a [ __ ] loser bro
hey by the way terry you've been mia i
miss you bro terry if i see you i'm
gonna slap the [ __ ] out of you the fact
that you were beat boxing into a vagina
is hilarious not just once
many times
this will
i suspect this will give you a girl like
eating on her [ __ ] just
like what the [ __ ] is this one time i
asked terry to come with me he would
when terry first moved to la he stayed
with us our my family and uh
you know he was teaching my kid you know
kids like beatbox and then i would go to
the comedy shows and then i you know i
brought him with me and then this one
comedy show i asked the guy hey can can
he beatbox at the beginning of the show
he beatboxed and like there were these
uh like hip-hop girls that like they
were they've been in hip-hop videos
definitely like you know they're banging
booty body everything right and they
were just so in love with terry like
they're just like we'll give you our
number and call a hangar and i'm like
damn it that's how you know like
once a guy whatever works man like once
they go to a bar they're gonna they're
gonna use
you know so at least you know i just
never seen any girl just look at
somebody that beatbox and goes you're
coming home with me
that's great terry dude good on you dude
but carrie also looks like a k-pop kid
too yeah no and he sings yeah he sings
he does all that stuff yeah i haven't
seen him in a long time he's been am i i
yeah terry
get back at us
i i i tell you all right he's like all
right and then that's it well as long as
he's alive that's good for real that's
crazy i didn't know you could beatbox to
get women that's [ __ ] nuts yeah it
was like dancers like i remember dancers
they could get whoever the [ __ ] they
wanted yes it still works yes no i i
definitely think that's one of the
reasons why i'm not not the main reason
obviously like lower reason
but there used to be so many gangs when
we're growing up like way more of course
it's economy more family all that but
also once the dancer guys started
getting all the girls i start i
noticeably saw a fade in like all the
gangpishes yes cause all those guys used
to get so many girls but then these guys
came along you know
[ __ ]
but you know about this
you know what it is i asked a couple of
homegirls about this it's like why do
you like dancers it's like they honestly
a few of them couldn't put their finger
on it but
when they finally came back with an
answer it was roughly the same thing
it's basically girls kind of equate and
i wonder if girls who are listening to
this right now can agree that
when they look at a guy dance they it
looks like they could [ __ ] really well
i've heard that man i was just gonna say
that i've heard a girl straight up say i
know the dancers are so good in bed
because why wouldn't they be yeah they
move so well because then you would suck
as if in real life you did it but in bed
you're like dead fish
oh i don't know yeah exactly what are
you doing to do that's why i just walk
around doing this just like
i was like you know what i'm good at
right this is this is my thing this is
my thing i swear to god like this is
right here
just like two fingers just like this
like if that's what you equate
everything with i stir the drink
with just the two fingers i had a guy
yelled out i i've been talking about
this at the club like you know i go it's
not about science about surprise and
this guy hold up it's about the finger
bro i'm like no it isn't bro
i'm like guys would be working out their
hand like oh
but you yeah you got big ass
you should just walk around so i just i
just do a thumb it's a thumbs up and i
just go right into it it's perfectly
fine that's not true at all but yeah
guys
dancers would always get all the [ __ ]
girls yes and it was that period of time
dude when uh
america's best dance group yeah an asian
guy's dominated every dude wanted to
learn how to dance and all these girls
[ __ ] they they inspired a whole other
generation of dancers now like on
instagram i see it too oh and all the
asian dance crews they crushed it
it's it's it was a
i grew up with uh
phil tyag the guy the
one of the the former leaders of
jabbawockeez so like he's from
sacramento grew up on the same block so
just watching like what he does blow up
it's amazing man like dance is such a
powerful thing i think like nowadays
people understand the importance of art
oh yeah because before it was just a
side thing like oh you do dance and you
do stand-up comedy and music on the side
you don't really do it as a career yeah
like full time but now people are
starting to really take the chance on
themselves and go out there and say
let's see what [ __ ] happens yeah
because i think like the hard part for
me too is
i just can't do something
half-assed because if i do that i'm
always going to think about a what if
you know i mean your situation you have
kids in a family so there's you know you
you have to balance no i i i definitely
look back if there's any regret
i i have multiple uh
i have many yeah i didn't uh continue
with piano i rebelled against that i
stopped that uh korean school stopped
that i would have been
so much more fluent
um but i think uh
with with comedy too like when i first
started to not have i was like i should
have taken like a real deep dive i was
so like
like loving that i had a group of
friends that i loved it was a group of
guys and girls and not only got married
but for me because in high school my uh
parents transferred me to
from burbank high to village christian
which is a kindergarten through 12th
private christian school
all white and i was a loner there for my
sophomore year and that just
transformed me traumatized me i'm
talking about like i ate lunch alone
every day
went to the library just ate lunch alone
i tried i made no friends i tried in the
beginning i literally had this one
moment would you try beatboxing
i remember this moment i'm like hey man
i was talking to this one guy and i'm
like oh you're going to lunch i go can i
go lunch with you guys and they're like
oh man they weren't being mean but
they're like oh car's full man sorry and
they drove off and i i feel like a abc
after school special movie also
oh my sorry
i remember uh this is a big rezama
clipper fan once i got my car this piece
of [ __ ] car i i went to clever games
alone the la sports arena is it because
you related to how much they were losing
yes and this loser team where you could
get an eight dollar ticket and go all
the way down they would win like 12
games a year they were the worst
by the way you're like the only true
clipper fan i know no there i know many
but i don't know many of you yeah like
you're the only one i know that i've
literally seen this dude posted about
the clippers since i first met him
it's kind of crazy from the 90s man
because if from then at that moment i'm
like man one day they're gonna win they
choke all the time so much pain
a little bit better a little bit better
there's a curse a little bit better
every year though
but that's why um
you know i just i just remember that
period in my life it was uh
traumatizing like most people that have
never experienced
eating lunch alone at school will never
understand that kind of pain
and so that helped me in life to like
when i led like collaboration meetings
or whenever other meetings like
anytime someone was new or alone just
immediately introduce them to someone or
i would talk to them because
they're not ever gonna come back unless
they feel like connected or someone
loves them or at least is interested
that's all i was thinking was like that
was like a
forrest gump you know when he was like
walking on the bus and he was like seats
take and sleets take and since i was
just hoping just for one person
i never really got made any friends at
that school i became close to some
people i played volleyball but that
experience
changed me forever anytime someone's
alone it like it like makes me feel
really bad because i know
how that feels like in a public setting
not like just randomly walking but in
like a group a meeting or
something i know they're thinking like
dude i feel so alone here right now and
i feel like
everybody else knows someone but i feel
like it's
painful so when did you find your group
of friends
not at not at school i just like hung
out a few people because i made the
volleyball team and then i you know
whatever
but uh
uh
my friends were at church yeah yeah then
the church split and then
some of my friends started partying and
then i was like i'm gonna try i'm gonna
start a part but i i did not know think
that i was gonna get so deep into it i
just
i i did ecstasy and that
just
yeah
that's all i was thinking about like
even when my first job was like i was
doing customer service and i was just
monday through friday and then we'd go
every weekend for years so did you is
that whole thing when you got caught up
and you never really fully
part of the reason why i i i half-assed
yeah for sure
i i definitely uh got caught up in that
but at the same time it's like i was i
loved
i don't regret that like i it was like i
felt so much love from that group yeah i
loved them so much and looking back it
was like
my 20s were like the best time
of my life and then i started
collaboration too and i was really
involved with the community so
i don't regret that and then i have kids
too but it look for when i see younger
people starting i'm like dude yeah
don't half-ass man like jump all in like
you like far east movement
james was going to law school with my
wife tammy and when he left loyola law
school tammy was like what are you doing
and he goes i'm i
you know i'm gonna do this
music group and tammy was like you're
crazy and then
popping bottles at that it was like
number one i was like yo it wasn't like
hey we're trying number one that's crazy
crazy and so it's like james proved to
me too like yeah
um
don't you can't half-ass the hard thing
though is
not everybody is as talented or skilled
or
can make a living
so
uh
at some point
life is the reality is gonna hit him
like
hey you know you can still pursue your
passion but not everybody's suppose it's
not meant to be everybody's at the same
level you know yeah
so uh
for me it's like
just never giving up yeah
do you
so when you say not everybody's at the
same level are you referring to yourself
or you're referring to other people
of course me but also not everybody
like for example like
i've seen dave chappelle perform live
like just freezed off the top of his
head for 30 minutes at laugh factory and
i need to write material for like a year
to do that like
literally like try it you know well dave
chappelle's a one of a kind no but then
there's no other there's a whole other
level i i like jo koy you know i've seen
him
and so uh but all respect to him he
grinded every night with laser focus
like he's someone that's never
half-assed so i i think about that like
if i um
were to ever do that half i know it
could have been much
further but i also know that i might not
have
my family like
i might have been on the road i know
myself i would have been party partying
my ass off you would have to give up a
lot i know i know myself i might i
probably be partying my ass off chasing
out just i i
would not have
i wouldn't have my family and it's so
humbling i have this day job
we work our ass off
my wife works
we get by and we have this tight family
especially during the pandemic
it was crazy but our kids were like
for them it was like the greatest time
ever mom and dad were home all the time
and we were just playing board games i
wasn't getting mad yeah did you beat
their ass
you cheated
like dude [ __ ] dad go to work already
get the [ __ ] out of here
pursue your dreams get on the road get
the [ __ ] out of here man
people deal with your jokes all day
yeah so um yeah that's that's really
true though cause i was you know i've
had this conversation uh with my fiance
too and
i told like i don't want to be absent
when i have kids that's the hard part
right um no matter what i a lot of
people say this too like all these other
celebrities do it you guys don't know
how much they work and how much they're
on the road
yeah these instagram photos shows that
they're oh they're always around they're
not around they're not they come in
they're omnipresent not i'm not saying
they're bad parents but this is what
they do their job always is in front of
their family that's just how it is and
um
it's not a judgment on on their parental
skills or whatever but they made that
choice but they also wanted to have a
family and they compensate with them
being away with money um to me i can't
do that i want to be with my kids my
parents weren't allowed to be around me
most of the time and when we did spend
time together is because i was working
at the store with them but we weren't
having fun they weren't asking me how i
felt they weren't asking me any of that
stuff we were all just trying to get by
24 7. exactly and they did the best that
they could they took us to yosemite
disneyland or whatever
however much they can you know with the
limited amount of money that we had but
that type of struggle in that
relationship i just don't want that with
my with my kids totally because i want
to be able to talk to them and
communicate with them ask them how they
feel they feel like they don't have to
hide things from me but when you when
you are around seldom and far between
how do you really develop that
relationship there's no shortcut to that
yeah at all there isn't they can sense
it too if like all of a sudden you're
like come on what's going on with your
friend why don't you open up to me you
can't force it it just has to be they
trust you over time yeah yeah friends
growing up together and you know like
chung and korean like just it only comes
that connection over spending time with
each other and in a positive way not
yelling you know i i literally if i have
a boy i can't wait till i catch him
jacking
i can't ah
he's hilarious he's gonna look at him
like hey you do your own laundry
now that's hilarious yeah
i was like everything is so stiff in
this house you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
it's awesome
does this too all the time but you just
too much
all right [ __ ] you know take reps
relax even when we work out we gotta
ease up a little bit all right
i can't wait
i think being a parent should be fun you
remember uh i remember i saw on youtube
that stephen young was on uh conan and
he did like he had like some like like
sex love making scene with a girl on
walking dead
and then he's he told conan uh his dad
just left him a message and he goes
oh stephen
you men now and he just hung out
because he saw that scene korean dad
that's a
having fake sex you men now you men now
that's you
when i look back at like all this like
funny [ __ ] i mean to us i guess like
people would think it's very
traumatizing as a kid but
having a weird family allowed me to do
what i do now because i've been able to
like compartmentalize all this weird
[ __ ] and trauma that happened and i've
been able to make comedy jokes out of it
because of just how ridiculous it is
yeah you know like i
even
that's why i always say to when people
try to bring a certain amount of
morality into comedy it's like how do
you do that because you
are laughing at my pain and the only
reason why you think it's acceptable is
because i allow you to laugh at it right
so when people go oh you can't make fun
of this it's like that's funny because i
literally just told a story where my dad
nearly beat me to death and then you
were cracking the [ __ ] up yeah yeah so
where's your moral barometer here like
you know i hear you i for the most part
i think 99
but uh
uh
for example uh
the tony hinchcliffe thing you know like
give it up for this filthy little [ __ ]
next there is something where you're
like oh hey man i don't know there's
there's a line everybody has lines
different i'm saying everybody's lines
different but there are moments when
you're like
because then you know i saw the comments
like who are you to judge or whatever
i'm like yo man that's offensive man
come on well for me it's like this it's
like
do that but it just has to be funny his
thing wasn't funny it wasn't funny so
that's why it was so stupid it's like
what's
the joke you know i think the thing i
didn't like i actually disliked the
asian guy more than i disliked tony
though because he did something that
makes us look like the stereotype that
people think that we are which is what
like which is cowards
he chose to record it like a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] sit there did he record it
or no i think he recorded it no she was
on stage someone else recorded it
somebody he took that and he goes oh
happy aapi month he didn't come up and
say to tony like bro he probably i know
i know peng i don't really i don't know
him too well but i i gotta take his side
on this one uh
he uh
he said tony came with his bodyguard
acted all friendly to him and everything
and he had opened for tony i think
before like this wasn't his first time
yeah
um you're i think you're i i would have
gone up to him
man-to-man face-to-face first and talk
it out i don't know maybe i don't know i
don't know that backstory
uh and then yeah i don't know that
backstory either but i feel like for me
i i'm always having to battle this this
line of like
i dislike it when people don't confront
somebody first first and they go to the
internet first true it's like if you
went he might have done this so i might
be i don't know i don't know i might be
super advanced right now so apologies
right but if that didn't happen
which is true i don't know this whole
story
but once again like you said if they've
been on the road together right he's
opened up for him that means there was a
relationship there somehow whether it
was super cordial or not the first thing
i wouldn't do is go up and do that post
this video what does that do right so
you cancel you're never going to cancel
tony tony's gonna still do comedy no
matter what more followers after he
exactly yeah you didn't do anything you
actually made it worse because people
that's the thing about like
representation too we're not trying to
tell show other asian people that asian
people are cool we already [ __ ] know
we're trying to get these other people
who don't know our culture don't know
have these really bad misconceptions of
who we are that we're not that he did
something that made people dislike asian
people more the people who already
dislike this i'm not telling us to go
beg for their attention or whatever but
one of the biggest things that asian men
are weak yeah right yeah what does that
do
if he put up a video of him coming up to
tony and being like hey bro what you did
you don't have to like my set or
whatever comedy just don't call me a
chick sure we'll draw the line there
yeah that would have been a little more
effective once again this is how i would
have dealt with it so i'm not here yo
you're right i agree with you i think i
already done it that way too you are
also more physically intimidating than
than paying
he tony would come bring a bodyguard
i've never heard of comedian bringing
bodyguards i've talked to the [ __ ]
bodyguard what he's saying is like that
acts that adds a weird level of like
intimidation let's say to ping like you
know yeah once again like i'm only
saying getting called my friends he's
getting called [ __ ] in texas
everybody's laughing and he probably
feels oh [ __ ] and like tony's a big
comedian i can't even and he's a
bodyguard like i've never heard of that
like yeah you're coming with your
physical entourage uh so
i agree with you you should have talked
to him
and and maybe film that like that should
have been the video i think that would
have been the [ __ ] because then
everybody would have respected him they
would have said like joe rogan did they
call his mencia exactly he doesn't have
to do that like i'm just saying i i
would have once again i'm being
presumptuous because i'm seeing it
through my eyes yeah and once again this
is like through the filter of somebody
who has dealt with that before and how i
dealt with it i felt the work better
because the the aftermath of tony
getting more followers from that is the
exact opposite of what he wanted or what
what he thought he was going to do
because his following got bigger and
stronger and it made people i don't know
he was trying to cancel tony though yeah
i think he's just trying to put it out
there like hey this is but that's him
trying to cancel him though that's what
that is it's him tattletailing
and i think when you do that in comedy
it becomes problematic right because i
think comics should be able to go up and
then show your skill up on stage and
then [ __ ] do it the other way yeah
but also problematically speaking too
it's hard for him i understand because
tony is such a bigger comic yeah you
know so he his weight is a lot bigger
but for me i always think about
if you're going to put a video out there
what is the objective yeah right his
objective was that he was trying to not
maybe cancel him but it was to get give
him heat
it was like okay i got to make this guy
look bad because he hurt my feelings or
he said something very offensive cool
maybe
maybe it could be a cry for help too
then that's still [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm sorry i
don't need that [ __ ] like you don't need
it you don't need to cry for help for
that type of stuff maybe he doesn't feel
like he he can go to anybody
for what because he doesn't have to go
to anybody is what i'm saying but if you
were in an area where there weren't that
many asians and they called you he's not
going to every other everybody else pk
he's just going to him the guy that he's
opened for multiple times no no i'm
saying i'm saying maybe the reason why
he
uploaded it because he was just like
i don't know what else to do like this
is you go up and talk to him she should
that's what i'm saying yeah so
i'm like i said i don't know him
personally but i know what tony's doing
now on his instagram he has this other
korean comedian and uh he has him come
up and make out with all the white girls
and uh he put on his uh
underneath the picture
uh this could have been you but you
wanted to play it was it definitely a
little
shot like you know don't mess with me
and i'm like what a douchebag man like
come on yeah like i'm not defending him
at all yeah you know what i mean i'm
just talking about as a comic as a comic
not not just as a comic person as a
person as like optics right i don't like
tattletailing yeah maybe it's just
because of how i grew up yeah like
when people people because people gave
me [ __ ] about this opinion they go oh
what's she supposed to beat him up who
said anything about fighting we're not
talking about fighting we're not talking
about aggressive yeah aggression none of
that [ __ ] i'm saying if you had a
problem with him not as a as a human to
human go up to him and say
don't say racist [ __ ] like that you
don't have to like my set
any of that stuff just don't use that
word [ __ ] because it's offensive to me
yeah you do that that's the bare minimum
you can do after he tells you to [ __ ]
off
now throw him to the [ __ ] wolves
because now that mutual respect isn't
there yeah because once again i have to
give him the benefit that and also him
too right i'd like i said to me that's
how i would have developed i agree when
i say the word [ __ ] or whatever that's
just how i communicate i don't feel any
way about this guy at all i don't i
don't really know him yeah it's just
when i saw the the aftermath of what
happened it wasn't the result i think he
wanted because he got support from the
agent i don't know if he's thinking
about maybe he wasn't even thinking
about
he had no idea what was going to happen
uh i mean listen
i think you're being really nice right
now when people things put out in social
media they know what they're doing
unless he's a [ __ ] dumb ass no
i don't think he's a dumbass i think he
knows what he's doing on social media i
think he he knew he was going to go that
big not big but he knew that was going
to get attention yeah nobody does stuff
on social media because they don't want
attention true do you know what i'm
saying now we're just being naive here
yeah let's be honest yeah he did it
because he knew it was going to garner
attention maybe not as big as he thought
it was yeah but there was an objective
on it he knows this whether he did it
you know subconsciously or not when you
put things out on social media
especially something that's heated
during aapi month there's an objective
to it whether you verbally say it or not
whether you have this whole mastermind
plan
i i agree with you he should have went
to tony but other than that
you don't think it was good that it was
exposed
no because it didn't do anything
it definitely exposed some people i saw
a lot of comics they were taking aside
saying
i didn't know [ __ ] was a bad word i was
like shut the [ __ ] up man but what
happened to them
nothing what do you mean like did they
get cancelled do they stop booking i
mean it's that's not the goals get
canceled but it definitely
look all the comics that saw this comic
say that are like oh okay like true
colors have come out even during the
whole trump thing true colors have come
out everywhere true colors but what i'm
saying is like
that's just how you feel about it what
i'm talking about is what does it do at
the end yeah do they
change their mind about something do
they sink their teeth in deeper about
how they feel about us
that's where it becomes because there's
no conversation there was a conversation
because a lot of people said well what
if he said no conversation with them not
with him see once again you and i are
differing on two things you're talking
about a conversation amongst other asian
people no no so i'm talking about he
didn't if he had a conversation with him
tony right yeah how different is that
doesn't it i'm not trying to be the best
thing to do exactly so this is what i'm
saying we keep trying to do this stuff
and change optics and make bolster our
asian communi asians no don't say that
word yeah right all those comics too
they know they're not supposed to say it
no but if you do it in an approach where
they feel like oh if this is for comedy
i'm telling people that you can have
individual conversations that'll exact
change way bigger when you do that it
just makes things more divisive no
that's how i feel do you see what i'm
saying definitely was not done right
but
uh i do know some comedians that left
tony hinchcliffe because of that and
they were like they apologized to peng
big comedians they're like hey sorry
that came out and it exposed a lot of
things about um
how
would he ever
say that introducing a black comedian
with an n-word
never
depending on the relationship
you think tony would do that
um
lucy k
and
patrice odile yeah louis ck has said the
n word but would tony ever
introduce
a black comedian and use and call them
the filthy little and probably not but
also thing too the reason why i also
disagree with this we also have to stop
doing would you do this to a black
person person i don't like
comparing like racial plight with other
racial plight so in that example i give
you one yeah patrice o'neill yeah and
louis c.k
right depending on their relationship
yeah so
i'm not saying that comedy has no holds
bar there's definitely you know talking
about somebody's family and race and
stuff like that i draw that line too
yeah right so when we because i heard
that example too would he do that with
somebody who's black and i used to say
that uh a lot too but then i have to
also realize on the other end it's now
we're using like this this race-baiting
tactic of would you would you would you
and it doesn't really create
conversation either so now my tactic
with like dealing with these situations
is always end goal what is the end goal
here right yeah when we do these type of
videos right and when we we say these
things are we trying to help the
perspective of the asian person who
already supports asian people or are we
trying to have a conversation with
somebody it's like so joe rogan
interviewed this guy who is a black
american that has conversations with
people who are in the kkk and gets them
out of the kkk he doesn't go to social
media he doesn't go around saying like
[ __ ] these people are terrible people
yeah yeah what he does he sits down and
he has a conversation
and it changes the behavior because you
could do it one on one yeah i feel that
when we do this as social media people
and we keep blasting people 24 7 which
i'm also guilty of yeah
i wasn't creating great conversation i
wasn't doing with individual people
every conversation that i had with an
individual person that had a very [ __ ]
up perception on race relations
i i influenced just a little bit i did
it over pandemic specifically during the
blm thing i had conversations with asian
americans a lot of asian americans who
didn't understand why blackface was
wrong and these are people who are in my
personal circle if i put them recorded
them saying what they were doing here
and i walked away they would have walked
away hating me and feeling the same way
yeah we keep doing this cowardice [ __ ]
where we go to the internet to defend us
because we feel helpless you are
powerful enough to have that
conversation with somebody else no 100
especially in the comedy world yes
there's also that we live in a world
where if there wasn't a guy that filmed
what the cop did to george floyd
in broad daylight they weren't filming
it nobody would ever know that even
it wouldn't have changed the world of
course there was someone there filming
peng and
and tony and gave him the video and
edited i don't know if peng did or
whatever and he did the happy api
day whatever right and it was yeah it
was pretty snarky should have talked to
tony but what i get it but one part of
me is like
all right it definitely exposed some
things like you know it definitely
exposed the way how easily
[ __ ] on asian asian people are you
know it's just they just people just
[ __ ] on us like it's nothing
you know and and we're so quiet
except for you you speak up for us all
the time not for us but you speak
like just whatever truth is in your
heart and it's like it's refreshing
because
also too i think my perspective is
i mean this is tony's saying this at a
time when asian grandmas and grandpas
are getting punched in the face stabbed
kill you know i'm saying like and he's
just calling a filthy little [ __ ] i'm
like
like come on man like
i i like i said i do understand that too
but i also have to look at like
like i said it's not even like a defense
of comedy i think
i just dislike the approach right yeah
like i just feel like like i said i'm
always talking about the end goal so if
the end goal is for us to make sure that
people don't [ __ ] with us
then i don't think that was the way to
do it because it just what i saw the
aftermath was people sunk their teeth in
deeper
and it did the opposite of what we
thought it was going to do yeah right
yeah so a couple of comments don't [ __ ]
with tony well guess what his following
grew yeah that's not what we wanted yeah
but imagine what would have happened
if who knows he might have been a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but then he would have
been dealt with either way if it was
like hey i talked to tony and i asked
him not to use that word he said [ __ ]
you i'm gonna use it anyways
then watch
how different his fanbase would have
taken it
it would have been different it's like
hold on this guy who's a a fellow comic
said hey everything's good just be
careful with that word yeah and he said
[ __ ] you
now there's change because it takes his
credibility away yeah so when we get
caught up in these emotions and we go
and we start tattletailing and we do the
video thing yeah in that type of state
and then we're you know we make the
george floyd comparison somebody's was
dying yeah at that point this is police
brutality versus no i'm just giving an
example of like yeah cameras are
everywhere now yeah i agree with that
but you know i think situationally
speaking in this once again i apologize
i don't mean to call him a [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] or whatever i just get heated
these are the words i use i'm pretty
sure he's a perfectly fine guy i just
once again for me i used to cry retreats
you would have thought i was big
i just say it all the time like once
again you know pain i apologize i don't
i don't mean anything by it i just get
heated because of what i saw happened
afterwards now i'm with you it was just
it just got worse and i saw people
continue to sink that teeth and i just
wished his approach would have been more
of
maybe he did do this but don't you think
some of those people that he gained that
two he went from 200 209 000. those 9
000
most of them were like trump supporters
they're like yeah but those people can
change too
true they can true they just need to sit
once you sit down and have a civil
conversation with somebody people i
agree people do not give people the
chance to change no i think don't allow
it through conversation individual
conversation is so [ __ ] important
yeah i had a conversation with the girl
about why her doing blackface was wrong
and she didn't understand didn't get mad
didn't yell at her i didn't record the
conversation i didn't put it on blast i
didn't do any of that stuff i sat there
two hours and i said and i broke it down
to her and what she was equating it to
was listen when i dressed up as this
black celebrity i'm just dressing up as
a celebrity yeah right i was like okay
cool but when you do that you're being
dismissive of this country's culture and
history right like let's say for example
like this right somebody saw um
a korean comfort woman in a film about
the korean war
they dressed up as a comfort woman
you feel the same way about that you're
okay with that because oh it it's just a
part of the movie but what they're doing
is they're being dismissive of your of
the history that happened in korea would
you be okay yes or no she goes i
probably wouldn't be okay i was like
cool now let's do this what's a really
good popular film i i mentioned uh kill
bill and she goes cool you okay with
somebody who's not asian dressing up as
lucy lou they go 100 fine cool now they
tape their eyes back
you okay she goes probably not well now
look at what you're doing same thing
well was she asian or black she's white
oh she was crazy she didn't understand
but once again she didn't grow up here
so if i had done the opposite and i put
her on blast on my huge platform
how terrible would have made that
conversation she would either hated
herself she would have hated me and
there would have been no conversation
and she would continue feeling the same
way that she felt yeah now
because i decided to see how you put the
guy on blast who jumped out of the
second floor yeah
he hates you dude
i didn't do a good job with that you
know what i mean so
when i when i look at that and also too
because he's a comic he has the gift of
gab he has the gift of conversation and
when you don't use those weapons and to
disarm somebody who's like on the same
level as you i don't think tony
hinchcliffe is anything above him else
above him so you got you open for
multiple times there was a way for you
to talk to him you're right he he i
don't i i'm not sure he might uh
have immigrated to america
he's in texas uh and he gave uh he
looked up to tony he gave a heartfelt
give it up for tony
hinchcliffe i've been there before like
wide-eyed host
just thankful to be and then the guy
straight up racial slur like it's like
it's like
yeah i i get it i'm not defending him at
all that [ __ ] was [ __ ] whack and
trash as hell [ __ ]
yeah and i think the cause is funny yeah
and the context was that was that he
didn't because i talked to a couple
people on twitter about why that
happened and they were at the show and
so when i talked to the people at the
show they said that tony hinchcliffe was
making fun of paying because he was
doing hacky asian jokes so he was making
fun of his set like oh look at me i'm
asian the only way i can make people
laugh is doing these hacky asian jokes
that aren't creative that's what that
joke was
so because he was doing those that
comedy set and i verified that that was
fine the three conversations
done without saying give this filthy
dirty little [ __ ] exactly but that's
what i agree with yeah you know but
i think a lot of people too were just
thinking that he just came up and
started ripping him
which his approach wasn't funny at all
that's why even like comics around are
still making fun of him like louie gomez
is his friend he [ __ ] roasted him on
a set because of how stupid his approach
was nobody agrees with the approach
right nobody even agrees with the worst
the usage of the word [ __ ] in no way in
that mouth with that i've seen some
comics say they never knew as a bad word
yeah well they're fine
and i'm like come on man then well let's
like relax we'll i'll have a
conversation with them and i'll be like
you're being [ __ ] stupid right now
yeah you know so
because you know we live in the 21st
century you [ __ ] knew yeah and if
you're saying you didn't you're just
you're being ridiculous yeah exactly you
knew so in that case like i said the
reason why i just i just saw the
aftermath and the conversations i just
didn't understand the purpose no i hear
you so it's a good lesson learned
thinking about future
i'm sure the stuff like that's going to
happen
all the time you know
peng did reach out to me he's like hey
you know i'm like yeah man when you're
in l.a i got this asia show come on and
we had it we had to talk about it i mean
all through
message i felt him i felt his pain man
and uh
he definitely is like it's not even
david and goliath it's like
did he feel intimidated by him is that
why i definitely think that was part of
it and i i definitely think that
physical stature has to do
in that type of setting you know with
how he
probably acted and uh but yeah i 100
agree with him so he should talk to him
he needs that emotional backing because
he felt he wasn't strong enough to do it
himself because i like i can understand
that once again i'm seeing it through my
lens like i've
i don't know i look at all the shows now
and it's like paying and four black
comedians and it's like paying in for
black community every show i'm like i
feel like they're the only ones like who
got his back i don't know i don't know
if the maybe that's just i don't know i
don't know so i'm just it made me feel
like he definitely should have gone up
to him but
i yeah part of me like just being real i
was like man
i've always thought tony's amazing can
be a roast comedian yeah one of the best
but then when you're saying like
the moral part of it is like
that was one of the first times i felt
like yo dude what the [ __ ] man what are
you doing i mean no nobody ever looked
at that and said
oh tony this is [ __ ] amazing right
and
i think when i first did talked about
this on the podcast because my words
word usage is really intense and very
whatever like it felt like i was siding
on tony you know i was just upset about
like i said the what the aftermath of
what happened yeah it didn't
there was nothing that was accomplished
maybe in his sense he got more notoriety
from it whatever well everybody was
accusing him of just trying to get more
shine if that's the case he failed i'm
just talking about numbers he's at like
2 000. yeah i don't think he was trying
to get more shine i think he's just
trying to get more clout he wanted to
bring down a bully you know yeah and i
think that's what his objective was yeah
and you're right that tactic has shown
not to work this is also like a personal
flaw of mine too because i used to get
bullied a lot and that tactic never
[ __ ] worked
st most bullies when you stand up to
them they ain't gonna say [ __ ] yeah they
know what they [ __ ] up they know
they're not doing something right
they'll start stuttering they'll laugh
about it or whatever but if he did that
and then once again
when you show like
personal solidarity when you show your
own strength and if you will recorded
that
it would have just it would have made
way more sense i agree especially
because he knew him
because he knew him and i think that's
there's just a lot of like working stuff
that's happening here that doesn't put
peng in a good light here in the comedy
community because people are calling him
a snitch now saying oh you're not going
to let people work material all this
other stuff right the comedy community
is so different yeah um and i think if
people haven't done stand-up
it's it's hard for them to kind of
understand that right because there's so
much [ __ ] up things that are said in
the comedy room that you can never say
anywhere else you can never say anywhere
else because people are gonna work these
jokes and by the time it hits the stage
it's completely different but they're
gonna go balls to the wall first and
then see after yeah once again not
defending tony hinchcliffe [ __ ] like i
said i said on the previous podcast if
he said that [ __ ] i would have walked
them body guards are [ __ ] not they
could have whipped my [ __ ] ass but i
would say what i want to say to you it's
like but
there's that thing that happens with
comics oh do we have to worry about
somebody recording our [ __ ] that's a
fellow comic and then putting it out
there for us to get crucified yeah so
for me it's like
then i mean part of it is
then just don't say that [ __ ] you know
part of part of it is like
don't say racial slurs like yeah 100 but
then uh yeah you should talk to the
person directly yeah and once again
through my lens what i would have done i
am not him um and it's easier for me to
judge on the outside if i was in that
situation what i would i would have done
yeah
i i could pretty confidently say i
wouldn't have done that
i'm 100 percent confident yeah
confronted tony i think i would have too
especially if i'm
if i'm opening for him and i'm excited
and he just does that i'm like that word
[ __ ]
it stirs something in me you know what i
mean like it it stirs anger immediately
so if somebody calls me a [ __ ] i
probably would have walked up on stage
grabbed that [ __ ] mic and i said say
that [ __ ] to my face because that shit's
like n word with a hard r to me so i
understand the emotions yeah but once
again we're all i'm just thinking about
objective yeah i'll go okay what am i
gonna do here am i going to
[Music]
how can i maybe it's because i've been
through this situation so much now that
i'm kind of versed well versed in it
yeah i know about what what it does i
know that sitting here as a comic having
taking a recording of somebody else and
putting out there is just not going to
do him justice and it's not going to
make anybody change their mind yeah and
it's hard because i think people just
get so get so sick of getting bullied
getting sick of having these racial [ __ ]
thrown at them all the time that they
just want somebody to just support them
and then back them up yeah but
but that's not the way to do it it's
just not the way to do it it just
doesn't change anybody i did that
multiple times and it did [ __ ] all
hell nothing dude and
uh a lot of my friends are seeing that
now they go oh you approach things a lot
differently i was like because i've been
able to affect more change just by
having a conversation yeah without
screaming without yelling and i can do
that for comedy purposes yeah i can do
that to make my community feel good but
when we talk in person i'm not gonna
scream at you i'm not gonna yell at you
you and i are just gonna talk just like
the way we are talking right now and
like i said
i'm a six foot guy i've been bullied i
lived in like terrible neighborhoods
i've
dealt with all this [ __ ] gangplay [ __ ]
gangster [ __ ] so obviously with him like
you said i didn't know he was an
immigrant that sounded like a weird
humble brag you know i'm a six foot guy
i've been bullied i'm like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you why are you bullying
because guns don't mean [ __ ] when you're
that big okay
i used to get punked and bullied all the
[ __ ] time as a kid so i know what
that feels like i know what it's like to
have somebody make you feel this [ __ ]
small and the only thing that changed
that is when i stood up for myself and i
didn't have other people do it for me
yeah because once those people are gone
you're still left by yourself true
those people will never be your
foundation that will never stop the
bullying when you stand up for yourself
and you take the blows coming at you
people think twice about it because
nobody ever bullies somebody that's easy
that's that's that's uh that's a very
difficult target the easy ones are the
ones they always come back for because
it's simple
i always said the thing too when i was a
kid you could bully me but i'm gonna
make sure that you have a [ __ ] hard
time doing it all day and they always
moved on to somebody else so when i see
him i see a little bit of myself right
so that's why i think i get so heated
and angry because i'm wishing bro you
could have done this so much better but
once again he doesn't have my
experiences he's also a smaller guy he's
in texas he doesn't have that support
community i grew up in california so
mostly you know if i look back and i am
kind of speaking out of turn because
he's not me and i can't expect him to i
just didn't like the aftermath you know
yeah no i hear you you definitely made
me think about a lot of stuff it was
good i i think
um
i was thinking about that in terms of
like just when you were talking about
the morality part of
comedy it just that part was the one
sticking thing i can't think of many
other things that i've been like what
the [ __ ] like that anybody else have
ever said on stage yeah i'm just so numb
to everything you know it's like
everything is funny but that was the one
moment yeah i i 100 agree with you that
too that's why i'm saying like if i if
that word came up i think i probably
would have walked on stage and i've been
like what the [ __ ] did you just call me
yeah you know what i mean it's like you
and i we don't even have that
relationship like honestly if there was
like a white dude that i knew and we
were dope friends and he and he said
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
if we're cool friends if we have an
understanding i might be okay with it
right
um
just because we have rapport like that
but if he's using it on stage to to mock
me like that and then people are and
they're laughing at the joke because of
just the word [ __ ] there's something
different there yeah because there's
power in that word and the way that you
used it isn't because you used it in a
joke it was funny because these people
think it's okay to call somebody [ __ ]
and that's when you stand up and you go
yeah hearing you out now it would have
been way more effective if you used that
video and then went back and clowned
tony yeah like you [ __ ] bring a
bodyguard you what cause you [ __ ]
yeah yeah [ __ ] what kind of comedian a
rose comedian yeah comes in like let's
say he had two so they flank him on each
side like he's a triangle four and then
he's like telling joe like yeah you
gotta like go back at him yeah you know
how funny would that have been you know
i mean it's like bro i'm like this
chinese immigrant you you scared of me
[ __ ] yeah like what are you
gonna do yeah tony hinchcliffe wouldn't
have done [ __ ] to him exactly yeah i
mean he'd probably get respect if he
came back at him but yeah and any any
white dude that has [ __ ] bodyguards
in texas is a [ __ ]
you know
like get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah i mean like you're very good with
your words but you're afraid that your
word's gonna get you in trouble so you
have bodyguards exactly that's some real
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes you know yeah so peng i
actually owe you an apology i'm sorry
like i get heated i i take back all
those negative negative things that i
said about you i wasn't really thinking
about your situation uh it's not too
late playing make a video and go back at
him
ah don't do that
i'll make a video for you too don't
worry about it like i said like i just
don't want people to think that i agreed
with you know tony yeah
i hear you what's the end you think of
thinking about it yeah yeah that's why i
i had to rethink how i do these videos
the best thing is to go to the person
but uh if you don't know the person
though
it might be a little scary no no no no i
think it's fair game as long as it's
funny
yeah clever you know yeah that's what
everybody's issue was with tony [ __ ]
it's like that [ __ ] wasn't funny bro
like you were just
saying [ __ ] just to say [ __ ] which the
contest was once again he didn't like
his hacky asian jokes which is fine you
could have done it without that word
[ __ ] yeah and it would have been way
better still wouldn't have been that
great honestly it still wouldn't have
been funny yeah but
you know it's just to go back to what
you were saying too is like
sometimes people just don't take us
seriously yeah so that word though the
weight of the word [ __ ] is just like oh
i know some people that'd be okay with
it yeah it's like cool that's not
universally true let's keep it as a
universal law for everybody out there
that word don't [ __ ] use it yes just
don't use it don't use it in public
don't use it any of that [ __ ] like i
said i might be okay with with a buddy
friend of mine that allows me to say
racist [ __ ] to him and he could say
racist [ __ ] back but i'll keep it
between us yeah it's not going on the
internet it won't go anywhere else but
between me and our him and our you know
our friendship yeah that's the hard part
man like it's a very interesting take
though because i just i i think like
from before you were talking i i was
just seeing it through
i think we always do this we put
ourselves in that position but we don't
think about who that person is and what
they were going through i'm only uh i'm
saying i was cause he reached out yeah
and uh and then i also know a couple
comedians that used to being kind of
tony's crew
that left
and it was like a
drama thing and i was like damn man and
it's like i mean it's whatever like i'm
busy in my own world just trying to
survive but as that thing's going on i
see it i'm see it online and i'm like
damn man i'm like this [ __ ] is crazy man
it's uh
especially for asians and how we're
viewed
past couple years man wow
also too you you're just true though i'm
a big guy so maybe i don't get a lot of
the stuff just because i'm loud mouthing
are huge
you're a big guy uh you're famous you're
well known and then you yeah you're well
spoke you're loud you're funny it's
gonna come off
different maybe he might maybe he might
not even have said the word if you if
you're opening for him you know i'm
saying like yeah yeah yeah he said it
because he is a small guy that he could
plunk and he has a bodyguard it's like
come on man it's like yeah he he kind of
had the car stacked he has joe rogan
he's joe rogan's crew man it's like dude
joe rogan's like the king
you know
of the comedy world and so yeah but you
know also joe rogan too i think people
forget joe rogan is the king of the
comedy world podcast prior to the
internet
so the internet now you have your own
gang you have your own crew yeah joe
rogan come around he's the king of the
podcast yeah he could come around and
tell you that oh this comic's not funny
doesn't matter if the internet thinks
i'm funny then
my fan base will come out and watch my
show you can go ahead and try to
discredit me as much as you want i love
joe rogan by the way i'm just using that
as an example of
you got to be a little more fearless now
like you can't keep making moves because
you feel somebody's going to shut you
down or get in your way yeah if you
develop your own fan base and you
develop a strong relationship with them
you'll be fine yeah you'll be 100 fine
yeah you know and also too like
when you're out there and you put your
stuff out like even in this podcast i
learned something so new about myself
right yeah i didn't realize that when i
was criticizing paying i was criticizing
myself because if i because i've been
through those situations and i started
getting heated because i started seeing
a younger version of myself as a kid and
i saw myself getting bullied and i saw
myself doing what he did and not getting
the result that i wanted and so it just
became something else it wasn't about me
looking at the situation and how he felt
and what he was doing i was i was
actually yelling at little 14 year old
13 12 year old david yeah and i'm like
oh no wonder i was so upset at him it
was outside of him because i was mad at
me but now you're right
paying
i don't know what happened maybe you
could break it down but yeah i
definitely think number one thing would
be just go up to tony man and then
and then maybe even asking tony like hey
uh like i'm gonna film this like you
cool because that's [ __ ] up man like
you know and then
that's probably the the best i only
bring up joe rogan is because he's so
huge like he has a cult following that
ping probably felt even more like
like dude this guy tony is in that crew
and chose the [ __ ]
beast like
you probably felt so
like you know it is a [ __ ] move but
i can't like help that's how i saw it
like yeah now that you even explained it
doesn't even seem like a [ __ ] move now
now i just see somebody who was no he
should go up to the person he was
cornered and put into an uncomfortable
situation and once like
because we've been to tech you've been
in texas i've been in texas austin's
more
cool but damn there's some parts of
dallas in houston yo yeah well when i
went to houston i saw a lot of asian and
black people so true but there's some
parts yeah it's different yeah like i
feel like for me there's always a way to
like break bread and find something in
common that you can really just work
that [ __ ] in um once again though if he
felt
vulnerable or just he kind of felt like
weirded out there's a lot of people that
are against him in that comedy club and
he's the headliner then that's a lot of
pressure for him to come up there and
grab that mic and just start roasting
the [ __ ] out of him that is going to be
kind of hard but then again i'm korean
you know i don't it's hard for me to
take [ __ ] from somebody that i could
just [ __ ] slap the [ __ ] out of so
it's like
i probably would have done it
differently but i don't i don't know him
like that and that is a lot of pressure
when i when you kind of explain it that
way for me that's kind of a
a little unfair of me to be like you
should have done this you shouldn't that
i wasn't in a situation but
yeah i just didn't like what happened
afterwards like when i saw those
comments of like people just
and i saw tony hitchcock's falling go up
i was like
it didn't do what it was supposed to do
it made it worse and i was like [ __ ] man
if only
the other thing happened you know yeah
it's a weird thing to navigate though
like how hard is it to navigate that
situation
it is
but hopefully peng will uh just keep
getting stronger as a comedian and uh i
mean tony's already amazing at the end
of the day i actually haven't seen peng
stand up but i've never seen it either
hey peng if you're [ __ ] funny dude
all that [ __ ] doesn't matter it's true
the funnier you are the the people just
love your standup comedy all that stuff
doesn't matter and then one day those
tables will be turned you're the dude at
top and then you guys maybe on a career
sense will be equal then what's he gonna
say
so
cream always rises to the top and that's
the success is always the best a version
of revenge yeah right because we can say
what we want but let's say peng stops
doing standard comedy after this then
he's the guy that's going to be
forgotten he was the one that was
whining complaining about another
successful comic yeah which i feel like
for him he's just going to continue to
get better and to go out there and then
show people what's up
right because imagine if he stopped
doing stand up after this then the story
ends well you have to do our show bro i
have to you said you were going to do it
once i'll open up for paying dude
peng i'll open up for you dude let me
open up for you bro i'm so sorry i was
wrong i apologize
um
it's going to be pang
davidson and then tony hinchcliffe right
there
that's gonna be a bomb-ass show i would
like to ask tony hinchcliffe why he
decided to use the word ching i'm so
curious yeah it's like in your mind what
was it just because you think comedy is
all you know a free-for-all or did you
feel like the backlash that you got from
my community was warranted or you
thought people were being sensitive
that's another thing too is he never
really came out and said i'm sorry
like it's how hard is that or he never
thinks he never thought he did anything
wrong it's like that weekend joe rogan
said no you're not going to perform a
show and then you got cancelled by his
uh agency
there's not even a moment of like oh
okay man i maybe i [ __ ] up like it
would be nice for him not maybe not to
do a public apology i don't i don't give
a [ __ ] about public apologies but for
him to contact penguin like
i shouldn't have used the word [ __ ]
like i didn't like your set and i
thought you're being really hacky so i
wanted to make fun of that but i crossed
the line
how good would that be and or just like
hey you didn't have to put that up but
i'm sorry man like yeah i don't know but
then it goes back to if peng didn't do
him do him that service too so why would
he do it back for him yeah so do you see
what i'm saying this is where that
personal conversation starts to really
create healing
so
we cut that bridge once that video went
up that bridge is now cut
that dude tony is never gonna learn from
that he has settled in i did this for
comedy comedy is okay for me to call
asian people [ __ ] and now he believes
that ten times harder he'll never
apologize there's there's uh
three there's three people i would love
to be here for
to uh
um not be on the i just wanna sit and
watch if i can
uh i think you and i can make it happen
but there's i would love to uh bring to
your podcast to um
have just have a conversation
one is bobby lee and kevin shea they
have beef right they're just do they
yeah long time and uh and i was so drunk
one time and i'll tell the story at
laugh factory uh i probably should go
but this will be our last thing um
uh you know i was hosting and then they
were on the same lineup and then uh i
kind of heard that they're you know
beefing you know they were on kim's
comedy together they had long history uh
i didn't know is that bad and then you
know where the bathroom is right there
like bobby was there and kevin and then
they were gonna like i think kevin was
gonna go up in the lobby and i was
fussed so i brought them together and
i'm like come on i give a speech you
guys are my korean brothers man i love
you both man i love you i was like let's
stop fighting man i was giving like this
pep talk
and they looked at each other and then
they walked away like walked away and i
go oh damn
i was like it's like dad i thought they
were gonna at least like but there is
like they still don't like each other
yeah and then bobby talked about it in
his podcast
and then uh how come he has keeps
getting in the fight with comics like i
heard about that he wrestled with ken
jung once too they threw down but
they're cool now yeah but uh
how about a funny dude yeah they they
like they like slapped each other's head
at some photo shoot and then they like
punked each other and
they got physical but ever since then
but i always wanted to like i'm like
[ __ ] funny just squash it you know
yeah and uh and then i know you guys are
cool now but just for fun i would love
to bring danny cho here and just just
sit in the middle and just have you guys
talk
and just say like what's a like hey dude
do you remember that slapping his hand
away
i'm sure he did something but i love
daniel i'm sure i i think he just felt
like ben is like up-and-coming guy that
looks just like me and you guys are both
like you know funny funny chubby korean
korean guys with the same glasses i
always said were you sure glasses too
yeah i had thick black glasses just like
we look like twins
i
literally if somebody told me to go [ __ ]
myself i'd go [ __ ] danny cho dude like
that's how it would be like
like if we if we got into a [ __ ]
fight nobody would know who's winning
because it would just be like two people
just [ __ ] wrestling each other at
that time he and i looked really alike
yeah i think for him he might took it as
like who's this new guy for me i was
like oh so cool that somebody looks like
me is so funny you know so we we had two
very different perspectives yeah because
i'm younger too yeah but also too i felt
at the time and i mentioned this before
is that he didn't he also didn't respect
me because he didn't know how long i was
doing stand-up yeah he thought i was
just some youtube kid yeah yeah oh he
does he's a and you know somebody told
me or my friend told me that he walked
around telling people that i'm just some
editor i'm like first of all bro i was
probably doing standard just as long as
you have you didn't know if i didn't how
did i do the stand-up set that's why i
took it personally because i didn't know
either yeah i didn't like it when people
were just like he's just the youtuber i
was like so when i came to the city i
was like well let me give me a [ __ ]
mic let me show you what i can do
so it's like i don't even need to do a
set i won't even practice a set i'll go
up with the old jokes that i have and
i'll just [ __ ] do crowd work let's
[ __ ] go so even when we did uh we did
that show with uh i think it was your
show it was in k-town or something i
forgot what it was but there was a bunch
of like korean comics that were on there
yeah i didn't do a set i just walked up
and i just
walked up i was like okay i can do this
without doing a set i've been doing it
for this [ __ ] long i don't know that
show is weird it's in a theater it was
like in a theater yeah it was weird it
was weird right but i was like cool
whatever i'll [ __ ] do this [ __ ] like
i don't need to practice a set i've been
doing this for so [ __ ] long and i did
it and i'm like cool don't say [ __ ] you
know don't say [ __ ]
cause at the end of the day if you're a
stand-up comic i'm not a great stand-up
comic but i've been doing it just as
long as you i can rock a [ __ ] mic
give it to me i'll show you what's up
and that's why the only reason why i
started going to the ice house i started
doing standard comedy clubs is because i
wanted to shut other [ __ ] comics up
it's like you don't know about my
background bro and there were comments
that were trying to give me advice and i
was doing stand up longer than them at
the time yeah it's like the audacity
it's like you just started you're the
baby like i've been doing since i was 16
years old don't [ __ ] tell me how to
do my set yeah i didn't know it's crazy
yeah it was a long time yeah so when we
came up the reason why i started doing
youtube was because i got sick and tired
of
just waiting around for something to
happen and i got tired of
having comics keep pushing me down the
line you go up uh somebody else's
your set got shorter your set got
shorter so i'm like i need to make a
name for myself somehow yeah i got to do
this somehow and look what happened
youtube i took all my old bits that
didn't work that were so hacky and bad
but when you chopped them up in these
short little videos it made sense it was
funnier so it's like cool all this
material that doesn't work let's throw
it in these videos and said or if it was
a set that i just did too much i threw
it in these videos
and they [ __ ] worked but then when it
came off to other comics was this guy's
a hack he needs these chopped up edit
bits to be funny it's like bro those
were all old sets that i used i just
repurposed them and put it back into
these videos so when you look back at it
if you look back at these old videos
they're just really performative short
stand-up sets i had to write a new set
every week for [ __ ] like seven years
you know you're hustling man yeah it's
like those were think about it those are
all little stand-up set jokes yeah that
just probably wouldn't have done well on
stage but no some of them i think it
would have hit hard yeah i think it
would have hit hard yeah you know and i
got tired because i was literally
running this library one
fire man that was a legendary one that
one's the one that that really got my
name out there
yeah you know that was a that was a
beast
yeah no but i'm just saying just for fun
just for fun because i think i would
love to have you i think i think it'll
end really cool but i think there'll be
some good awkward moments
i would just sit here and i would just
start rubbing his he's thighs cause i
because the thing is like because i
would love to ask questions too i'm like
hey daddy did you were you uh why did
you disagree
with david because because he looked
like you
and you're like who the [ __ ] is this guy
because i'm sure that's what it was
that's all it was you know i i know my
personality
i'm just more like
hey to everybody in this so even if a
guy looked like me and he's coming up
and he's like funny and i i know even
though i feel threatened
because i've already it's already
happened many times uh and then i'd be
cool but maybe danny just felt like man
there aren't that many
spots
you know but he's and like who's this
guy i mean in all honesty just to be
completely objective it's like what were
you threatened about you're way funnier
than me your stand-up is way better than
mine what do you have anything to feel
threatened about well you're you two
you're you're you were blowing up hey
cream rises to the top no matter what
yeah you know this is why he's up in
korea you know being at the forefront of
doing standing in south korea some
revolutionary [ __ ] right that's what i'm
saying
like cream always rises to the top
there's absolutely no way especially
during that time he and i did a stand-up
set at the same thing people would think
that i was funnier than him there's no
way
absolutely not you hear that danny
i know you're watching
i love you brother yeah hey but jenny
you're doing some revolutionary show in
korea man yeah i even shouted about the
last podcast when i told the story
because it was always one of those
things that i look back on and i'm like
i when i when i first saw him and i was
thinking that he looks just like me i
always think how funny would it be if we
did a video together yeah it would be
great it would have been amazing yeah
and then but once i found out he didn't
like me i'm like oh [ __ ] this guy then
what the hell i didn't do nothing is
there any other i'll tell you one
i only have don't like one comedian in
the world but is there anyone else that
you've ever had like weird awkward
uh not anybody that i know but when i
first came to la um i was put on a venue
as a youtuber
and it pissed me off because i was doing
stand-up yeah it wasn't collaboration
right
i don't know i think collaboration's
different everybody's a youtuber okay
everybody's a youtuber but um it was it
was it was at the ice house and they put
youtuber on it oh okay and that [ __ ] had
my blood oh i think i saw uh you know
these to put clips up i saw you too and
they put youtuber and i was like
what the [ __ ] and i
the funny thing was that ice house thing
came last minute and i hadn't done a
stand-up set in so long i was so [ __ ]
nervous because i couldn't i haven't
done
i didn't prep anything and they were
giving me like a decent amount of time
to do my set but when i was about to go
up
i still remember that's still up i was
about to throw up because i was so
[ __ ] nervous because i was pushed as
like one of the headliners i'm like what
the [ __ ] i don't
i'm not ready for this i haven't done i
haven't practiced a set
so when i was up there
before i went up there was another
comment he was like oh you're the
youtuber right and i just looked at him
i was like i'm gonna [ __ ] suck this
dude in his face i know what he's doing
right he goes oh look cause i've been
doing standing for quite a while now
like you know if you need any tips like
just ask me before you go up oh how long
have you been doing stand-up he was like
about like three or four years i was
doing nine at that time and i'm like
okay good luck and he went up there and
he started bombing and i was just in the
crowd laughing my ass off like
obnoxiously like
just cracking the [ __ ] up just watching
him bomb in silence step back down he
kind of gave me a dirty look i was like
good set guy i was like [ __ ] amazing
bro you're the funniest you know it's
like bro shut the [ __ ] up but that's the
last time i i kind of dealt with an
[ __ ] comic but that [ __ ] got under my
skin i still hold that against that
[ __ ] till this day the fact that
he just looked at me like i was a piece
of [ __ ] oh like looked down he looked
down on them that should hurt my
feelings yeah i said it again it hurt my
feelings
this one i probably shouldn't even say
it but uh i
it's like i need to let it go that's why
i'll say on david's podcast
uh i will try that for last comic
standing waited hours and you get like
two minutes this is why i'll always love
greg geraldo he was one of the judges
and i did my little thing
and um she goes yeah yeah yeah you have
a lot of promise man like you know i you
know i think i i think you're funny and
then natasha legero she goes
really
like she's trying to be the simon you
know it's like film that part come on
like really and he's like yeah and then
i was just looking at it she wouldn't
even look at me and i had brought her up
at long beach left factory left as a
whole like i'd met her before yeah
like i've
was always that's why maybe that tony is
clicking instead it's like i've brought
her up on stage and natasha you know
and she just [ __ ] on me and it was on tv
and i never got on that show and uh i
just know that would have been a game
changer for me it would have been a
great little boost for them
to get a lot more spots and it just
crushed me man i walked out of there and
i just was like wow like why why'd she
say that
and i've never seen her since but if
she's blown up but every time i see her
name i'm like [ __ ] this
what's she doing now she's big she's a
big comedian she does like uh
podcasts and uh she performs everywhere
she's like a headliner oh really she's
funny she's she's funny and she i
remember when i first met her i'm like
wow she's really pretty
and then after that she just became so
[ __ ] ugly to me i'm like you're so
hideous yeah
i'm like that was so rude
i i only know of her name but i've never
heard her stand up or seen her before
yeah but she's pretty big
she's big i mean like she's not like the
up upper upper tier but she's like that
next level of she's big you know she's
she's on tv she's like she's been on the
comedy central roast
she like roasts people oh [ __ ] like
really pretty
but uh but that moment when she did that
i just i was like that was so did you
ever ask her why i never ran into her
but if i run into her i will like yeah
and i've i always told me that if i run
to her i'll be like do you remember just
to see what she'll say like
like do you remember that and she'll
probably be like i don't even remember
of course like she just probably wanted
to be the simon cowell of that judge
panel she was sitting on the same thing
on the far right you know yeah but you
know last comic standing roads like no
but if you get on everybody who's gone
on it gives you
it like there's so many stand-up
comedians now
it's so hard to get spots but when you
have a
credit then you immediately you don't
have to work like i have to eat can i
get like you have to work to get spots
it's so hard to get swords but also too
for you though like i i still feel like
because you're still a part of the
generation of scarcity mentality right
you're also doing things in my personal
opinion backwards like
you're you are now in a position where
you don't have to do that
you have so many social media outlets
and so many things that you can do
to really boost your [ __ ] out there if
you wanted to headline something within
this next year you could focus on your
social media stuff
you have so much bits and jokes put
these into videos and create it yourself
right yeah you could i don't if if that
was what you wanted no i will well even
if like if that's what you wanted you
could have been like hey i want to come
on your podcast regularly you don't
think i would have put you on this
podcast regularly i i didn't know till
now i started out i swear to god i'm
really thankful man why are you asking
the wrong people is what i'm saying like
you know you're asking these you know
people hey can you put me up why don't
you ask your community to people who
support you well i'm i am working on
like new material to i put out one
special it it no it nobody watched
didn't do anything for me so i'm like
all right now we gotta work on the next
one so for me it's like getting spots
but i hear you like in terms of working
backwards like utilizing
social media and
that or or utilizing people who [ __ ]
with you
right i think it's i i think you're in a
position now where if yeah if you ask
the favor or something not even a favor
it's like hey i'm trying to like get my
name out like if you need somebody to
come on the podcast just as a guest so
we could talk topics yeah because not
every every podcast is about the
individual yeah we just talk about [ __ ]
like the best part of this conversation
was probably us talking about the korean
church [ __ ] and then you know you
changing my mind about paying
right that's what the podcast can be
about i used to watch you guys on uh the
jk news man i loved it it was very
conversational yeah it's like different
that's just what it is it's different
topics and then us like going back and
forth on things so i feel like for you
you should be hitting up people within
your network that [ __ ] with you right
because the people that [ __ ] with you
are the ones that are gonna push you the
hardest yeah so if you were just like
hey man like i'm trying to get my name
out there right now
let me come on a few podcasts what the
[ __ ] was i going to say no
i don't know i don't know to be honest i
don't know
i'm so in my own married dad world like
sucker dad world like i i'm like
i barely have time to
consume anything you know what i'm
saying like i'm
people i'm barely finding out about
squid game i'm like what the hell is
this [ __ ]
everybody in the world is watching i'm
like okay like even after this i'm like
yeah i need to go home and watch that
like i brought uh this dude uh jason
cheney on here right funny as [ __ ] he is
so so [ __ ] funny can i can be honest
with you if there's one guy that i would
think like i understand why danny would
feel like who is this guy right yeah not
that i look like jason cherry but when i
saw him i literally went
[ __ ] this guy's funny man well that's
why i brought him on here i literally
hit him up only because i saw his stand
up and i'm like funny nobody knows you
enough yet yeah and if i'm gonna push
somebody who's an asian asian american
that i think is genuinely funny yeah
you're going to be the next one he's
really like i don't give a [ __ ]
don't give me any i just want you to be
on this podcast so people know how
[ __ ] funny you are and he is
hilarious hilarious man yeah like he's
he's big time yeah like cause i've seen
other people who were like on social
media and they're trying to do stand-up
and i just look i'm like god you're not
good enough yet bro yeah like you need
more time like
don't put your stand-up out yet you know
who's i think one of the best is uh
fahim anwar you know fahim that sounds
hell of a what
faheem anwar i think he's the next like
his [ __ ] is [ __ ] he's my follower
he's amazing i don't know but i would
love to
bring him here too just to hang out
so you two can just [ __ ] around did he
blow up because of
his name is hella familiar right now i
mean he
he's just a pure comp like he goes up
like every night and just says new [ __ ]
but his chris his best [ __ ] is like
he has a bit about uh orgy etiquette
he's like are is there educated orgies
like dude he has a pretty big following
he's like 70k yeah he just put some [ __ ]
like like he just stand up all the time
man and that's what i'm saying like when
when people who are on these other
platforms like social media people don't
understand why i took stand-up comic out
my title because there's people like
fahim you you guys are up there i'm not
yeah you're up there more than i am so
that title of standard comic to me is
very sacred it's very deserved yeah
right and so
everybody just calls themselves a
standard comic now just because you go
up on stage a few times it doesn't make
you a [ __ ] stand-up very true right
yeah technically it does but i i have
like a certain level of respect for
stand-ups because of the grind and how
hard it is to perfect your craft you
know and then when you have this huge
following you go up you get a couple of
giggles and then you tell your friends
you killed it it's like bro i was at
that show you did not kill it
you did not kill it at all and also the
show that you were at you put it on
blast so you had your fans come out
there go to a cold crowd who doesn't
know you and make them laugh yeah then
then we'll see what's up yeah you know
and i think like
the crap the stand-up comedy is being so
watered down now and everybody's calling
himself a stand-up comic yeah it bothers
me especially after the pandemic god
there's so many comedians like yeah
there's so many but there's also so many
comedy clubs yeah there's so many man i
just went to this one called the
hollywood comedy and i go who owns this
and they're like gelling and i go
the comic she goes yeah like the chinese
girl she goes she she owns it and so she
performs here all the time too and i go
damn i'm like yo dude that's crazy yeah
so these people just open up their own
comedy clubs yeah it's dope though you
know i appreciate it you know so you
know just going back to just the craft
that in and of itself like i i
appreciate standard comics a lot that's
why bringing you know comics here is
it's big for me nobody knows who jason
cheney was anytime i mean people who go
to these stand-up comedy clubs they see
him he kills it yeah but in terms of
like his social following a lot of
people don't know how [ __ ] funny this
guy is yeah because he's not a social
media guy yeah he's a he's a stand-up
comic yeah and when i looked at his
comedy the first thing i felt was this
guy's [ __ ] funny and i'm also a
little jealous at how good he is me too
so when i first saw him like damn dude
this guy's so good man yeah yeah and i
look at him like if i feel that tinge of
jealousy and i look at him and i enjoy
him that that means that's how much how
successful i want him to be yeah because
feeling jealousy about somebody like
that not in a way where i want to take
you knock his hand away
hey get the [ __ ] away from me dude
just kidding we love you daddy i know
you're still watching
watching him go up like just watching a
few clips and i was cracking the [ __ ] up
i'm like bro you're
great at this yeah yeah jason's so good
man i i had that
change of jail i was like man [ __ ] this
guy he's so good yeah he's really good
he's gonna do a collaboration show too
dude he's coming he's he's a [ __ ] he's
he's a beast headliner material yeah
he's
when i see him open up for people i'm
like you don't need to open up for
anybody well he's doing the eliza
schlesinger show he's a he's been doing
the haha for a long time yeah he's still
good man
yeah jason's really good yeah who are
other stand-up comics that you that did
you see coming up that you think are
really good i mean there there's the
lady crew there's uh atsuko jenny uh
she's been doing it for a while
like they're blowing up man um who else
is there that i'm missing there's like
there's a lot of girls that are they're
uh they're on their hustle they're
killing it
um
i mean
it's crazy how
this collaboration show we have uh three
asian comedians every first friday at
the laugh factory come out if you're in
l.a uh
and then we have one non-asian comedian
as like a friend guest whatever
and
i remember a long time ago it'd have
been like work to like really book it
out
but we're booked out to like
april may you know oh all the seats are
sold no no no not not the tickets like
the lineups oh right yeah like it's just
like it's just booked out and like i
asked bobby lee i'm like hey he's like
yeah i promise i'll come through
um but i'm just like i can't believe how
many more comedians there are now like
you know and some of them just been in
the game for a long time
cause sierra
she's newer she's newer oh yeah i don't
but paula gotta like ron jossel like uh
justin rivera like there's a lot of
comedians i've been in the game
for a long time like you know walter
hanshaw felipe
[ __ ] oh i forgot about walter bro
[ __ ] maniac dude walter's a crazy
person
because every time i see him like first
of all who the [ __ ] double fist two
pitchers of beer together
like this guy is a [ __ ] creature i i
just don't know every time i see him i'm
like did you just come out from a sewer
like
what is this he's like you want a drink
and he hands me a picture i'm like this
is for a group of people what is this
everywhere
where is this this is everywhere this is
walter hong 24 7. shout out to walter
too this [ __ ] just would walk
around just drunk as [ __ ] and i'm like
dude i don't i don't even think they
could serve liquor here where did you
get this beer like he was so [ __ ]
funny to me she's just this weird human
being you wanna talk about weird koreans
that guy right there walter walter is my
young
um
dumbfound is getting good man oh yeah
he's another guy too every time i say
i'm like [ __ ] him he's so talented man
damn dude other than other than dancing
that guy does everything man he's just a
really talented he's doing the actor
rapper
rapping everything yeah he's he's doing
uh insta-hope captions on his instagram
yo every time i have to give him some
type of [ __ ] this will i know you do it
dumb you [ __ ] stop deleting my [ __ ]
comments you son of a [ __ ]
oh let's be writing some [ __ ] and he
just like [ __ ] this guy deletes my [ __ ]
dumb i swear to [ __ ] god you delete
one more of my comments
he put up this photo of himself recently
and i just typed in i was like
the f the best part about this photo is
the fact that you took a tiny little
tripod and you set it up and you said
he deleted that i think he deleted it
you deleted that
dumb i went back in the comment was god
i was like where's this comment
[ __ ] yeah do keep writing it
please send it to me and then i'll copy
and put it on there too oh my god
oh
man yeah because he's been grinding out
stand up now for a few years no dumb is
so talented man but yeah the uh selfie
model thing you could kind of calm down
but
if you really put a truck like if if
your uh girl didn't take that picture
come on bro i was like i'm like you're a
little too dressed up in your own place
is it correct we were talking about too
how now that we're you know we're older
we don't care about
the whole
appeasing to all these like kangpes and
hyungs and you could really just say
whatever the [ __ ] you want that a lot of
people used to put like masculine
feminine feminine [ __ ] on but then he
tweeted like a while back to i remember
i saw this he goes yeah i'm about to
start my juice cleanse and i wrote back
i was like i would have never thought
one of the hardest battle rappers on
earth would have tweeted that he's about
to start a jews cleanse what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
you know but that's the thing about
being free and being able to say what
you want to say now yeah you don't
really care and it's allowed him to kind
of just skyrocket now yeah you know he's
an artist now he's yeah he's definitely
definitely an artist yeah
yeah well [ __ ] we've been doing this i
know yo i just looked at like i'm like
what almost two and a half hours and a
half yeah over two hours two and a half
hours well for you shout your stuff out
thank you thanks for
uh inviting me over here man thank you
don't [ __ ] take me man
no no no
thank you thank you because i know you
said like
um
you know find the people that [ __ ] with
you and ask them but like i'm just not
in a situation where i'm gonna just
start like hey man can i come on your
podcast then send an expert can i come
on your podca
i can i guess but like you know but you
it just organically happened you're like
hey you want to come on i'm like thank
you but what if it didn't happen though
closed mouths don't get fed dude yeah i
know but it's like right now
we're building a room in our backyard
our home our place is crazy right now
and so like my focus is not to do
anything like out but when i told tam
i'm like i'm gonna do david silva's
podcast she's like oh wow like you know
it's like
certain things i'm not gonna lie like if
it was a guy who just started his
podcast i probably wouldn't do it on a
monday night
you know i always i do have a lot of
people that just starting ask me and i
if they would listen to this podcast
that's why yeah well i actually i'm
honest with them like in the beginning i
could i literally
can't i can't right now i can't like do
everybody
um
but uh every first friday at the laugh
factory in hollywood
uh we do collaboration the laugh factory
used to be called asian invasion finally
thank you jamie masada just like the
[ __ ] called it asian invasion jamie
masada the owner yeah and so hey what
the [ __ ] that uh tony rock christopher
he always used to say that's like
calling the black comedy knight black
attack actually use the n-word attack
and he goes he goes black people attack
the mic tonight he goes he goes what the
[ __ ] is asian invasion celebration he
goes that's like ninjas are going to fly
out of the
that's
funny dude but uh
come to collaboration at the laugh
factory every first friday and you can
go to laughfactory.com there's the
tickets and uh er next year davidson is
going to come through he said come out
and watch me [ __ ] bomb
so
bad just just to just to give everybody
a heads up
first 10 sets that i do in the year i'm
gonna bomb every single one because i
gotta test out this material i haven't
done stand up in so long at the end of
every second you're like my name is
danny chill thank you everybody
remember i remember justin
justin rivera i don't know if you know
his filipino comedian is bald he uh he's
really funny but he does magic too and i
i i always always book him to these
korean bank things i i'm because they're
like do you know entertainers i would
emcee and then i would invite justin and
sometimes you'd be all right but one
time he like it was like a big cream i
think like a humvee bank or like yeah
he bomb right like 400 i just she's in
ajima's and at the end he goes my name
is joe coy thank you
[Laughter]
that's funny that's the best thing ever
everybody everybody's joking everybody's
like
dude i'm literally going to do that [ __ ]
now there i'm taking that [ __ ] i'm going
gonna call every time i bomb i'm just
saying my name is danny chowder buddy
thank you for this no he's not danny
i really am though
but what about your socials oh uh
everything pk comedy pk comedy.com pk
comedy down instagram
and uh thank you man
thank you i'm an old ass man dude 45
three kids
she just started bro still jerking off
hey dude that shows you still got it man
i don't even have it like that anymore
well uh jesus brains every thursdays and
sundays um up until next year next year
uh starting january it's only going to
be once a week so
it'll be longer podcasts but it's going
to be uh only once a week so we'll see
you all next time make sure you follow
pk on all of his socials wait for him to
put up his stand-up shows go watch him
he's super [ __ ] funny guy i look up
to in the stand-up comedy world so make
sure that you go check him out and we'll
see you all next time thank you peace